jallet assemblée nationale de manière
plus large il polarise un peu tous les
débats depuis quelques semaines
maintenant autour d'eux des aspects
éducation de 2,2 de ce texte nous avons
été les uns et les autres sollicité dans
nos départements par de nombreuses
familles qui s'inquiètent cette
évolution législative qui peut
apparaître disproportionnées par rapport
à l'objectif à atteindre à savoir la
lutte contre le radicalisme islamiste ne
souhaiterions donc monsieur le ministre
que vous puissiez nous exposiez en
détail le lien qui établit le
gouvernement entre l'instruction en
famille l'affaiblissement des principes
de la république
l'islamisme et les écoles de fait mais
l'intérêt de ce projet de loi ne se
résume pas loin s'en faut à la seule
problématique de l'instruction en
famille l'article 22 qui prévoit la
fermeture administrative des écoles en
contrat ne respectons pas la loi et le
durcissement des peines encourues par
leur directeur nous pose un certain
nombre de questions évidemment vous le
savez les régimes d'ouverture et de
fermeture de celle-ci sont des sujets
particulièrement sensibles au sénat
d'avion vous le savez était à l'origine
par l'intermédiaire de notre collègue
françoise gatel d'un texte qui est
aujourd'hui je crois fait d'abord qui a
été voté et qui fait d'une certaine
manière référence sur la réflexion et
dispositifs de contrôle par rapport à
ces écoles hors contrat le sujet on le
sait délicats depuis 1999 le conseil
constitutionnel estime en effet que
l'enseignement privé est une composante
du principe constitutionnel de la
liberté
de l'enseignement enfin il y aura sans
doute des questions relatives à la
situation des activités sportives
l'article 25
nous avons auditionné il ya quelques
semaines dominique schnapper présidente
du conseil des sages de la laïcité qui
nous a indiqué que celui ci travaillait
sur un vade-mecum sur la laïcité dans le
domaine du sport cette initiative est
bienvenu tant qu'il ya une impression de
retard pris par le monde sportif sur ces
thématiques et cette problématique
peut-être nous donnerez vous quelques
éléments complémentaires à ce sujet dans
votre propos liminaire monsieur le
ministre je vous propose de prendre la
parole pour une dizaine de minutes je
sais que le thème sans doute
nécessiterait plus de temps mais comme
nous avons un certain nombre de
questions à vous poser et je ne
commenceront après votre propos
liminaire parcelle de notre rapporteur
stéphane pieds noirs
ainsi qu'à nos collègues je ne sais pas
si son pari je ne vois pas des deux
autres rapporteur de la commission des
lois dominique vais rien et chacune le
stage connu à qui nous avions aussi
proposé de devenir peut-être ont-elles
des questions j'ajoute aussi mais nous
en avons tous l'habitude qu'un certain
nombre de nos collègues sont présents
derrière leur écran et pourront
intervenir
évidemment s'ils le souhaitent de ce
ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je suis très heureux de me retrouver
devant vous à nouveau pour beaucoup
d'entre vous je vous ai vu hier soir sur
d'autres d'autres sujets dans
l'hémicycle et évidemment c'est très
important que nous ayons cette cet
échange sur un projet de loi qui comme
son nom l'indiqué vise à conforter le
respect des principes de la république
et ce faisant de conforter notre école
je viens donc à la suite de mes
collègues ministres d'autres personnes
d'autres personnalités que vous avez pu
entendre
et comme vous le savez l'enjeu de
l'école est extrêmement important à
l'intérieur de ce projet de loi ce n'est
pas anormal puisque dans notre pays
l'école c'est la république si je puis
dire et la république c'est l'école nous
le vivons actuellement avec l'enjeu
d'ouverture des écoles qui signe bien la
fiction de la france pour son école et
le caractère central de l'école dans
notre conception de la vie collective et
donc de la république nous avons donc
des enjeux dans cette loi jules ferry
dans sa conférence célèbre de 1870
disait avec l'inégalité d'éducation je
vous défie d'avoir jamais l'égalité des
droits non l'égalité théorique mais
l'égalité réelle bien ça résume un peu
le projet républicain l'arrêt la
centralité de l'école dans la république
et d'une certaine façon les enjeux qui
sont là aujourd'hui parce que derrière
le sujet de la laïcité il ya aussi le
sujet de l'égalité des citoyens devant
la loi et
sujet de la neutralité du service public
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ces
circonstances très particulières
nous mesurons plus que jamais le poids
de tels mots pour notre école
donc les articles dont nous allons
parler même temps ne porte pas seulement
sur la défense de la république qui est
évidemment points majeurs mais aussi sur
la défense des droits de l'enfant et sur
tous les sujets dont j'aurais vous
parlez les deux vont ensemble
je pense que c'est intéressant de se
dire cela ce que parfois quand on dit
défense de la république ça nous parle
mais il ya certaines oreilles pour
lesquelles ces mots sont abstraits bien
chacun doit comprendre que dire
défenseurs et puis dans ce contexte là
c'est dire la défense des droits de
l'enfant tout simplement essayer les
droits de l'enfant correspondant à un
intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
correspondant qu'à une bienveillance de
la république pour chaque enfant de
france parce que personne n'avait droit
absolu sur les enfants c'est l'honneur
de la république et donc de la société
que de défendre chaque enfant dans
toutes les situations et c'est vrai
évidemment pour le droit à l'éducation
qui est d'ailleurs consacrée par des
textes internationaux et bien entendu
consacré aussi par notre constitution
il ya en france quatre façons de
réaliser le droit à l'éducation de
l'enfant
il peut aller à l'école publique il peut
aller dans une école privée sous contrat
il peut aller dans une école privée hors
contrat
il peut aussi suivre l'instruction en
famille ce sont ces quatre modalités que
l'on doit examiner si l'on veut
s'assurer que les droits de l'enfant
sont respectées par les quatre
circonstances carte circonstances étant
protégé s'agissant de l'école publique
d'abord vous le savez depuis le début du
quinquennat
nous avons beaucoup travaillé sur cette
question et vous y avez fait référence
monsieur le président c'est important de
le dire parce qu'il m'est arrivé
d'entendre et compris à l'assemblée
nationale parfois un argument consistant
à dire mais pourquoi cette loi ne nous
parle pas de l'école publique et ne nous
parle finalement surtout que l'école
hors contrat et de l'instruction en
famille
mais par dix parce que nous n'avons fait
que ça parlait de l'école publique
depuis trois ans sur ce sujet là et nous
avons agi donc cette loi
bien entendu vient compléter ce qui a
déjà été fait il y aura sans doute
d'autres choses dans le futur de nature
législative ou de nature réglementaire
sur ces questions mais il s'agit de
venir en complément des choses les plus
fondamentales qui ont déjà été établis
vous avez cité la loi gatel agi ce titre
monsieur le président c'est un des
éléments
une des premières choses que j'ai faite
en arrivant a été de créer le conseil
des sages de la laïcité dont vous avez
auditionné la la présidente comme vous
l'avez rappelé cela nous a permis
d'avoir un corpus de normes
nous avons notamment le vade-mecum de la
laïcité qui a permis au professeur et à
tous les personnels de l'éducation
d'avoir un point de repère dans la vie
quotidienne
chaque fois qu'une question se pose et
je crois que non grâce à ce travail qui
continue encore parce qu'il ya un
travail matricielle du conseil des sages
de la laïcité vis-à-vis de l'ensemble du
système scolaire par exemple pour les
enjeux de formation initiale et continue
je viens d'ailleurs de charge et
l'inspecteur général honoraire jean
pierre robin d'une mission sur ces
questions de formation ils l'exercent
évidemment en lien avec le conseil des
sages de la laïcité donc ce rôle
normatif et matricielle du conseil des
sages de la laïcité a produit de
premiers fruits et déjà je dirais les
fruits de la clarté
ce qui est important en deuxième lieu
nous avons créé des équipes valeurs de
la république dans chaque état chaque
rectorat de france ce qui signifie que
dans les trente rectorat de france il ya
désormais des personnes qui viennent en
appui de tous personnels de l'éducation
nationale ou tout groupe de personnel se
trouvant dans une situation
s'apparentant à des problèmes vis-à-vis
de la laïcité et donc ses équipes se
viennent en appui et bien entendu cela
vient évidemment en contrepoint de tous
ceux qui peuvent parfois pensez encore
que l'esprit l'éducation nationale
serait le pas de vagues
le fameux pas de vin ou le fameux
problèmes sous le tapis qui soi-disant
caractériserait notre maison cela fait
partie des clichés
peut-être que ça puait devrais je mon
but n'est pas de parler de ça maintenant
de ce qui est certain c'est que ce n'est
pas vrai aujourd'hui ça ne doit pas
l'être demain et donc jeudi de nouveau
très clairement et très solennellement
celle inverse du pad vague qui à notre
principe d'action cet autrement dit un
système de signalement et les équipes
valeurs de la république sont là pour ça
de même que les îles et des systèmes
dédiés notamment d' alerte par email ou
par téléphone qui sont possibles pour
tous personnels de l'éducation nationale
donc je leur dis très clairement et à
tous au travers de vous même et
messieurs les sénateurs
une personne qui a un qui considère
qu'il ya quelque chose qui va pas du
point de vue la laïcité dans son école
dans son collège ou dans son lycée à des
moyens de faire appel à l'institution
pour ne pas être seul face au phénomène
mais au contraire avoir l'appui de tous
genres toujours nous ont-elles peut
avoir besoin
nous savons qu'il ne s'agit pas de
sujets abstraits l'assassinât de samuel
bâti nous l'a malheureusement rappeler
et nous devons affirmer la force de
l'institution derrière chacun de ses
membres et nous devons aussi protéger
les membres de notre institution pour
conforter les principes de la république
nous avons donc réalisé un ensemble de
mesures et ces mesures ont trait donc à
l'école publique notamment
mais elles ont eu trait aussi évidemment
à l'école privée hors contrat au travers
de la loi gatel vous l'avez rappelé
cette langue et elle nous a permis
notamment d'être beaucoup plus efficace
désormais pour empêcher des ouvertures
d'écoles hors contrat et
en tant que ministre de l'éducation
nationale est désormais de la jeunesse
et des sports
j'ai pu lors des deux précédentes
rentrées interdire des ouvertures
d'écoles dans des proportions qui
n'étaient pas possibles précédemment et
donc on a les premiers effets positifs
de la loi gatel en revanche cela le
système prévu pour la fermeture des
écoles hors contrat qu'on a continué à
montrer des limites parce que beaucoup
trop complexe beaucoup occupé favorisant
je dirais le che chicaneries de ceux qui
sont visés et leur permettant de
continuer leurs activités parfois
l'exemple typique dans la région de
grenoble de l'école que j'ai souhaité
fermé qui pour lesquels nous avons une
décision de justice nous donnant raison
en première instance mais avec un appel
suspensif qui permettait à cette école
par ailleurs en commune comme posant
problème de continuer à exercer je pense
que ce sont des choses qui sont pas
normal et c'est pourquoi cette la loi
qui vous est présentée durci les
conditions de fermeture de des écoles
privées hors contrat
enfin durci plus exactement là peuvent
renforcer la possibilité pour l'autorité
de fermer grâce aux fermetures
administratives qui pourront avoir lieu
désormais
enfin il y a le quatrième modalités
d'enseignement l'instruction en famille
c'est je ne ne m'a pas échappé le sujet
qui a fait le plus couler d'encre depuis
que ce projet de loi existe
notre but a été aussi la de remplir un
vide juridique
il est frappant de constituer de voir
que depuis les années 1880 finalement
très peu de choses ont été précisées en
matière d'instruction en famille et qu'
il y a eu d'une certaine façon une forme
de d'anarchie en la matière et de régime
est extrêmement faible de même que je
disais qu'en début de quinquennat il
était plus facile depuis fort longtemps
d'ouvrir une école que d'ouvrir un bar
en france ce qui n'est plus vrai au
moment où je vous parle de la même façon
l'instruction en famille était laissé
une sorte de deux régimes extrêmement
simple permettant les abus et ses abus
se sont développées ces dernières années
parallèlement au développement
quantitatif de l'instruction en famille
parfois on me dit mais pouvez-vous mieux
nous aider à cerner le phénomène tant
que certaines auditions vous ont permis
de le faire je crois que vous avez reçu
la rectrice de versailles par exemple
madame sniper mais il est vrai que nous
le sert non mal et je le reconnais
malheureusement bien volontiers mais ça
fait partie du problème justement c'est
que le phénomène fait que certains
enfants sont
sous le radar mal identifié pallie pas
identifié et qu'on ne saurait supporter
que des écoles clandestines se développe
en france ceci nous renvoie non
seulement au sujet des écoles hors
contrats mais de l'instruction en
famille puisque de la moitié des enfants
que nous découvrions dans des structures
clandestines que nous avons pu
démanteler ces derniers temps et est
officiellement inscrit à l'instruction
en famille tout ceci ne signifie pas que
nous voulons en finir avec l'instruction
en famille et nous avons surtout été
beaucoup aller coûte au cours des
derniers mois du conseil d'état
évidemment vous l'avez vu mais aussi des
associations des acteurs de
l'instruction en famille je n'ignore pas
la structure et l'émotion que ça là ça a
parfois suscité chez certains et je suis
capable de l'entendre et de la
comprendre et nous avons donc fait
évoluer le texte en permanence d'une
façon à ce que les exceptions envisagé
permettent de maintenir l'instruction en
famille dans l'ensemble des cas qui ne
pose pas de problème particulier
mais nous devons garantir aux enfants
ont seulement une qualité pédagogique
autrement dit le fait que l'enfant
progresse tout au long de l'instruction
qui le reçoit mais aussi nous devons lui
lui garantir qu'ils ne sera pas sous
l'emprise d'un quelconque radicalisme
qui dès l'âge de 3 ans et même je dirais
dès la naissance peu obérer ses droits
et c'est tout à fait ce qui peut se
passer c'est encore plus vrai peut-être
des petites filles que des petits
garçons mais c'est vrai de l'ensemble
des enfants donc très concrètement la
disposition qu'ils aient présenté en la
matière d'anti 21 nous permet d'agir
contre toutes les formes de
scolarisation clandestine
et de façon plus générale contre les
abus de l'instruction en famille donc il
s'agit d'agir contre un abus de droit ce
qui est plus que classique dans le
domaine juridique
l'abus de droit est évidemment le risque
qui accompagne chaque liberté et être
capable de préciser une liberté c'est
pas être amené à la supprimer ou à
l'affaiblir c'est au contraire la
conforter parce qu on la définit
davantage et cette définition manquer et
c'est pourquoi je considère que ce qui
vous est présentée en la matière
conforte les droits de la de l'enfant
autant que cela conforte la république
et cela n'est évidemment en rien une
atteinte à la liberté de l'enseignement
ou à ses principes
bien au contraire je pense que ça compte
contribuer à mieux définir cette liberté
d'enseignement qui comme toutes les
libertés compris les plus les plus
précieuses pensons à la liberté
d'expression
mais ces sites évidemment toujours un
cadre comme le dit la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen du 26
août 1789
je vous remercie les fans pieds noirs
merci président merci monsieur le
ministre de propos introductif qui
brossent le tableau de ceux de ce texte
en tout cas sur les articles concernant
la commission culture sont sur les
articles 21 25 en gros sur l'île
question a le sport pour reprendre
certains nouveaux propos sur l'ios dont
on voit que l'exposition à la fois
médiatique et de nos boîtes mail est
inversement proportionnel à l'ampleur du
phénomène et aux effectifs concernés
qu'en revanche je ne partage pas votre
votre analyse sur la l'absence de
volonté d'interdire l'instruction en
famille puisque c'était c'était
l'intention initiale du président de la
république nous sommes revenus dans ce
texte un régime d'autorisation sans
doute lié à une analyse un petit peu
plus fine du risque constitutionnel que
corps est constitué
l'interdiction pure et simple de manière
factuelle à rentrer 2020 c'est un peu
plus de soixante deux mille écoliers
si on se réfère à l'étude d'impact qui
sont enfants qui sont instruits en
famille dix sept mille d'entre eux
bénéficient d'une instruction en famille
tu n'aides réglementés c'est-à-dire pour
des motifs médicaux essentiellement ou
pratique sportive de haut niveau
artistique
ces dix sept mille élèves pourront
continuer rassemblement à bénéficier de
cette instruction en famille puisqu'il
rentre dans les critères 1 2 3 qui sont
exposées dans l'article 21 et on peut
considérer que c'est j'irai d'une
autorisation quasi automatique pour ces
cas là il y a donc 45 mille élèves pour
lesquels les problèmes d'un choix libre
d'un choix est un choix pédagogique qui
peut être un choix de vie familiale qui
peut qui peut être aussi un choix fait
pour des convictions comme cela se
produit sur le choix d'une école privée
sous contrat ou par contrat pour
lesquelles les familles choisissent
librement d'inscrire leurs enfants
le texte je les dis a beaucoup évolué
depuis sa présentation initiale en
conseil d'état
puisque le quatrième critère notamment
pour évoquer la situation propre de
l'enfant a beaucoup a été élargi la
première question c'est donc sur
l'estimation du nombre d'enfants sur les
45000 qui répondent sans problème sans
difficulté au quatrième critère est donc
qui seraient éligibles à cette
autorisation qui pourrait continuer à
effectuer l'instruction en famille et en
29 mille enfants qui seraient à re
scolarisés d'après l'étude d'impact nous
avons été beaucoup sollicités par les
familles sur ce sujet là qui craignent
une forte restriction de leur liberté de
choix de ceux de l'une des quatre
modalités d'enseignement que vous avez
cité en introduction la deuxième le
deuxième sujet concerne les articles 25
et 25 bis relatif aux sports sans doute
que certains de mes collègues auront des
aussi des questions là-dessus mais les
acteurs du monde sportif que nous avons
auditionné nous ont fait part d'une
inquiétude vis-à-vis du contrat
d'engagement républicain qui s'impose à
toutes les associations et
particulièrement aux associations
sportives mais l'absence d'informations
précises sur son contenu laisse dit
dubitatif les acteurs du sport que nous
avons donc auditionné les les
discussions portent sur l'obligation de
de signer un document qui aura des
conséquences juridiques pour ces
associations sans savoir ce qu'il
contient à sans savoir à l'avant ce
qu'il contiendra ça pousse question et
le sujet est aussi de savoir qui
participera à l'élaboration de ce
contrat aujourd'hui rien n'indique dans
ce texte les
la déclinaison et le contenu réel de ce
contrat d'engagement républicain
troisième question s'agissant des
certificats médicaux de complaisance
1 peut-on imaginer on sait que c'est un
réel sujet ça fait une forme de
séparatisme avérée peut-on imaginer un
système de deux médecins agréés pour
lutter contre les certificats de
complaisance qui sont pénalement
condamnable
aujourd'hui pour des dispenses deux ps
pour des motifs qu'on peut considérer
comme fallacieux vous avez confié une
mission sur l'allergie au chlore qui
découvre les maladies au fil du temps
donc mission qui est confiée au conseil
des sages de la laïcité
pouvez vous nous dire quand seront
remises c'est conclusion journal mais je
vous propose de répondre aux questions
du rapporteur après on passera une série
de questions de représentant par groupe
bien merci monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur en plusieurs
points je reviens pas sur l'ensemble des
commentaires que vous avez fait qu'ils
sont dans dans le débat simplement pour
finalement votre question centrale
s'agissant de l'instruction en famille
c'est finalement vers quelles
conséquences vont nous mener les
critères tels qu'ils sont retenus c'est
comme ça que je l'assumerai sur votre
moto votre question il est évident que
le en plus de la mesure de la loi qui
est résultera de de notre de vos travaux
il y à ce que nous ferons sur le plan
pratique qui parfois peut relever du
domaine réglementaire ou tout simplement
de l'organisation de l'éducation
nationale un engagement que j'ai déjà
pris dans l'hémicycle à l'assemblée
nationale c'est le fait des taux fait
les équipes des rectorats c'est un point
très important puisque j'ai mentionné
tout à l'heure les équipes valeurs de la
république elles sont sûres sur d'autres
sujets même si sa référence même enjeu
celui des valeurs de la république
elles sont là pour aider notamment dans
l'école publique
répondre aux problèmes de violation
éventuelle de la laïcité mais de
nouvelles équipes vont se structurer sur
des bases déjà un peu existantes
puisqu'il ya déjà du travail qui se fait
sur l'instruction en famille et qui
permettront de faire beaucoup mieux
l'instruction en famille ce qui
d'ailleurs permettrait aussi de mieux
accompagner ceux qui la réalise en
respectant la loi dès lors qu'on est
dans un régime de d'autorisation et non
plus dans un régime de déclaration
il faut d'abord examiner les dossiers
mais il faudra aussi avoir un travail de
terrain
d'autant plus que vous l'avez vu et là
aussi dans un sens qui va loin dans
l'ouverture
nous avons établi à partir du passage à
l'assemblée nationale que les mesures en
vigueur le serait à partir de 2022 que
l'année 2000 21 2022 serait une année
transitoire que celle ci permettrait
d'ailleurs de développer le contrôle de
l'instruction en famille et que
lorsqu'une famille aura vécu ce contrôle
et que l'équipe de l'éducation nationale
considéra que les choses sont faites en
respectant les règles cela vaudra
autorisation pour l'année scolaire
suivante ce sont ses tunes c'est une
approche très ouverte à mes yeux et qui
signe ici mieux bien le fait que d'une
part nous voulons justement
professionnaliser cela ça va de pair
avec ce que j'ai précédemment sur vide
juridique mais qu'on pourrait appeler
aussi vide administratif sur ceux sur
sur ces questions jusqu'à présent et ce
faisant perdre distinguer ce qui va et
ce qui ne va pas ce qui permettra aussi
probablement et même certainement au
cours de l'année 21e devenir plus précis
sur l'impact sur les eps que précisément
on a du mal aujourd'hui
encore une fois je le reconnais à faire
un diagnostic de l'ampleur qualitative
du phénomène quantitative on sait le
faire
vous avez rappelé les chiffres
l'ensemble des élèves dans l'instruction
en famille mais qualitativement dire
quels sont les cas problématiques c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus dure tant qu'on
n'a pas franchi un cran dans notre
capacité à contrôler mais nous savons
que problèmes y lire par exemple député
choix de l'essonne de disait lors des
débats parlementaires précédent donc
comme base si je veux dire l'instruction
en famille avait connu un développement
tout particulier dans les communes où on
repère tout particulièrement les
phénomènes de radicalisation et le
préfet de l'essonne avec qui je veux
parler de ces questions dans le cadre
d'un comité départemental de lutte
contre la radicalisation qui sont des
structures très efficace pour faire
travailler de manière interministériel
et des agents déconcentrés de l'état et
les collectivités locales
bien entendu disait que l'instruction en
famille se développer particulièrement
dans les milieux radicaliser mais ce
serait ce n'est pas possible de d'en
dire davantage d'un point de vue
numérique mais c'est aussi le sens de ce
que nous faisons que de devenir
plus plus précis plus professionnel sur
sur ces enjeux donc évidemment plusieurs
milliers d'enfants qui seront concernés
c'est fait pour lutter contre le
radicalisme islamiste
il ya aussi d'autres sujets qui peuvent
que venir avec ses textes par exemple
développe aussi de cette de cette façon
là et les droits des enfants sont
malmenés par l'appartenance de certains
parents à des sectes qui peuvent amener
à toutes sortes d'abus et puis d'autres
abus qui peuvent exister sur les enfants
et qui ne relève pas l'appartenance à
une religion ou un groupe mais de
pratiquer
c'est problématique de la part des
parents bien sûr ces enfants là seront
si vous me permettez l'expression sauvé
par le par le nouveau cadre
je suis parfois surpris du fait que l'on
brandissent l'argument du faible nombre
d'enfants qui serait concerné d'abord ce
que je ne pense pas que ce soit si
faible que ça et l'avenir nous le nous
le précisait ensuite parce que chaque
enfant compte quand bien même ce serait
un enfant et bien sûr c'est beaucoup
plus qu'un chaque enfant compte et donc
nous allons clairement renforcer notre
capacité à protéger les droits de
l'enfant dans un cadre démocratique et
républicain est encore une fois une
famille qui respecte parfaitement la loi
et et les le bien-être de l'enfant n'a
pas lieu de s'inquiéter sur cela c'est
donc d'ailleurs dommage de voir que des
énergies tout à fait respectable et
positive se mobilisent contre quelque
chose qui en réalité ne les menace pas
c'est un peu un appel à la sérénité que
je lance le si on veut être serein on
doit regarder en face cela est au
contraire on voir que cela va conforter
les bonnes pratiques est tout simplement
mettre fin aux mauvaises aux mauvaises
pratiques
s'agissant du de ce que vous m'avez
demandé sur le domaine le domaine
sportif
le contrat d'engagement républicain
correspond à une logique que nous
considérons comme très importante
puisque elle consiste à responsabiliser
les acteurs et notamment les fédérations
nous avons beaucoup parlé avec le
mouvement sportif
je pense au cnosf ocp sf et ont été
consultées
nous avons nous sommes engagés à écrire
le contenu des contrats en étroite
liaison avec le mouvement sportif et les
thèmes auxquels on peut tenir dans ses
contrastes et les valeurs de la
république
c'est l'égalité hommes femmes c'est la
lutte contre toutes sortes de dérives et
notamment la radicalisation et il est
bon que ce soient pas dans une logique
verticale mais dans une logique de
responsabilisation
de la chaîne des acteurs de terrain donc
les fédérations bien sûr et au travers
des fédérations les clubs
j'ai souvent été amené à dire avant même
cette loi et au delà des enjeux de cette
loi que les valeurs du sport rejoignent
les valeurs de la république
lorsqu'on fait faire du sport aux
enfants ont d'une certaine façon on les
initie à une forme d'éducation civique
et en valeur de la de la république
l'esprit d'équipé l'engagement le
respect d'autrui etc
c'est un peu ce qui se joue au travers
du contrat d'engagement républicain
c'est finalement la fidélité du sport à
lui-même
si je prends la charte olympique vous
savez on dit parfois que la laïcité ce
serait quelque chose de très français
mais quand on dit ça c'est pas forcément
en bonne part s'est dit ça à l'air de
dire que c'est désuet que c'est que
c'est pas la mode que c'est pas
conformes à des choses beaucoup plus
attractive qui se passe aux etats-unis
ou dans d'autres pays du monde
je m'inscris en faux complet contre ça
je pense que la laïcité
quel que soit le nom qu'on lui donne
sous tous les cieux est un concept
extrêmement moderne extrêmement adaptée
aux enjeux collectifs de notre époque
compris en dehors de france c'est pas
pour rien que dans la charte olympique
on voit des choses qui en réalité ne
prennent pas le nom de laïcité mais il
n'y a pas le nom mais il ya la chose et
le sport il est naturel que le sport ne
soit pas envahi par des éléments qui
enfreignent la neutralité politique et
religieuse tout en respectant les
libertés et je dirais un certain bon
sens
qui est qui doit régner dans ces
matières donc le contrat d'engagement
républicain c'est tout ça c'est
finalement une sorte de fidélité du
sport à lui-même au travers un
engagement que les fédérations peuvent
d'autant plus prendre que l que quelques
ça correspond aux valeurs qu'elle
qu'elle affiche depuis toujours sur les
certificats médicaux de complaisance
merci de les évoquer comme vous le savez
nous avons et vous l'avez rappelé
missionné donc des inspecteurs généraux
pour nous rendre compte de cela au
travers de la question de l'allergie au
chlore c'est plus globalement le la
question en effet de ces pratiques qui
ne qui ne sont pas acceptables
donc on nous remontent régulièrement des
sujets du terrain donc nous savons que
le problème existe et compris de la part
de chefs d'établissement et professeur
de psg voit le sénateur grosperrin et là
il m'a déjà alerté sur cette question
qui l'avait vu sur sur sur le terrain
mais je crois que c'est le cas de
plusieurs d'entre vous le diagnostic
donc justement là aussi reste à parfaire
parce que pour l'instant c'est juste des
remontées empirique du terrain d'où
l'importance de l' enquête qui a été
lancé par la direction générale de
l'enseignement scolaire en la matière le
travail des inspecteurs généraux et
l'enjeu de l'accès aux piscines qui est
un enjeu d'égalité homme femme qui est
aussi un enjeu de sécurité
vous savez à quel point la ministre
déléguée roxana maracineanu est
attentive au savoir nager
ce serait paradoxal qu'on développe le
savoir nager et qu'on développe et qu'on
accepte les pratiques qui empêchent
certaines jeunes filles en particulier
d'aller d'aller à la piscine
c'est d'ailleurs un des mérites de la
laïcité que nous amener à être logique
et donc si on défend l'égalité hommes
femmes on ne peut que défendre la
laïcité est donc le
le nuj attend les résultats nous
attendons les résultats avec marlène
schiappa de cette mission
dcm d'ici à l'été de façon à pouvoir en
déduire des éléments opérationnels pour
la rentrée scolaire prochaine
une première série de questions
commençant par annick billon qui doit
être en visio annick est ce que tu nous
entends annick oui oui parlons ça y est
vous m'entendez oui oui bonjour monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre vous
excuserez g de l'écho vous aussi
également annoncé bon tu entends très
bien non bon alors très bien
donc merci monsieur le ministre pour
cette audition et je regrette de pouvoir
connecter ma vidéo mais j'ai peur que
vous ayez le mal de mer donc je vais
faire deux points d'intervention dans ce
matin 1
d'abord vous dire monsieur le ministre
que je suis profondément attaché à la
liberté d'enseignement un deuxième le
point nous sommes tous je pense aussi
attaché à la protection des enfants et
c'est sous cet oeil là que j'ai regardé
le texte qui nous est proposé ayant été
rapporteur de la loi gatel je pense
qu'elle a montré son efficacité
et comme vous l'avez dit on voit
évidemment des difficultés pour réussir
à fermer une école
la ferme et dans le plus rapidement
c'est souvent effectivement sécuriser
des enfants donc bien entendu je pense
que la fermeture administrative est
peut-être la seule solution pour
protéger des enfants
sami aussi en évidence cette corrida tel
est son application surtout la
difficulté du contrôle alors oui la
prise de contrôle
mais ce qui est ressorti quand même dans
les auditions c'est que mais les
contrôleurs les inspecteurs ne sont pas
toujours formés aux méthodes
alternatives pédagogique et que ce
déficit de connaissances fait aussi que
ces contrôles peuvent être parfois
à charge et ça a été le cas dans un
certain nombre de témoignages que j'ai
pu avoir mois sur l'instruction en
famille il ya un véritable déficit de
connaissances par rapport à ces méthodes
nouvelles de pékin des logis et donc le
diagnostic qu'on peut faire du coup de
l'instruction en famille ou des écoles
privées hors contrat et parfois aussi
faussé parce ce déficit de connaissance
je dois aussi pointé un deuxième point
c'est le rôle des collectivités dans
l'instruction en famille au cours des
trois dernières années je me suis rendu
compte après le passage de la loi gatel
puisqu'il mettait à mener ne parlait
souvent de cette proposition de loi
devenue loi dans les collectivités une
méconnaissance certaines évidente des
élus du rôle qu'ils ont à jouer dans
l'instruction en famille et dans dans
dans le contrôle avec souvent ils se
sentent totalement démunis donc est-ce
qu'il faut pas monsieur le ministre voir
le rôle des collectivités aussi dans
l'instruction en famille vous avez fait
tout à leurs références
et puis un deuxième volet dans cette
intervention qui est plus lié à
l'actualité
le 25 février dernier ministère de
l'éducation nationale avait annoncé a
annoncé pardon que les élèves des lycées
hors contrat si peu les élèves inscrits
au cned devront tous se passer leurs
épreuves de spécialités sur stable en
juin 2021 alors je ne vous cache pas
qu'on a été assailli de mails sur
l'annoncé de ces nouvelles modalités
parce que clairement lors du bac 2020
tous les élèves étaient logés on peut si
je peux m'exprimer un signe à la même
enseigne
ça va pas être le cas cette année et il
ya véritablement une montée de colère et
d'incompréhension de la part de ses
élèves dans les écoles privées hors
contrat et les élèves inscrits au cned
donc si vous pouvez également répondre
parce que des lui mais ce sont des
élèves à qui on avait dit à l'automne
quand même qui est toutes les épreuves
du bac été annulés et d'ennemis mais
certains vont devoir en passer sur table
c'est une trop
fonde injustice ils le vivent comme ça
de tout évidemment
donc merci monsieur le ministre est
désolé pour le déficit de caméras chers
collègues des monsieur le président on
met les pieds sur terre avec jacques
bernard magner
moins bien merci monsieur ministre pour
les explications vous avez apporté je
trouve quand même que vous êtes un peu
dans une forme de contradiction par
rapport au débat que nous avions pu
avoir autour de la loi dite gatel au
sujet des établissements scolaires hors
contrat et vous nous dites que vous avez
réussi grâce à cette loi a fermé
certains établissements moi je dis vous
auriez pu ne pas les autoriser overy
encore certain si vous aviez accepté les
amendements que nous proposait à
l'époque par ce qui est en train d
clarations et l'autorisation on voit
bien aujourd'hui que ce que vous ce que
vous vous proposez de fer sur
l'enseignement en famille bien pourrait
être fait aussi de la même manière pour
les établissements scolaires par contre
je ne vois pas bien pourquoi on fait un
sort particulier alors mon option
instruction en famille rassurez-vous mon
groupe politique vous soutiendra sur
cette initiative parce que il ya
effectivement que vous l'avez dit un
certain nombre de dérives qui peuvent
arriver et l'école pour nous c'est
d'abord l'école publique privée sous
contrat qui affiche un certain nombre de
principes républicains qui sont connues
de tous l'enseignement en famille on
connaît moins bien on connaît quelques
raisons pour lesquelles qui sont
dérogatoires est certes justifiée pour
que les enfants soient sécurisés dans la
famille quand c'est possible mais il ya
beaucoup de choses et fait suivant qui
échappe à la fois au contrôle et à la
raison je dirais parce que quand vous
l'avez justement dix personnes un droit
absolu sur un enfant voire sur ses
propres enfants
je pense que tout enfant a droit de
vivre avec ses pairs d'avoir la mixité
sociale et qui dont il a besoin pour se
former socialement et tout le monde sait
ça je ne prolongerai pas le mât
discussion là dessus mais il n'empêche
que je ne sais pas comment vous allez
pouvoir nous expliquer cette recette
positions contradictoires que vous avez
pu avoir entre
les établissements hors contrat et les
instructions en famille compte tenu des
l'autorisation par rapport à la
déclaration
je voulais évoquer aussi tout à l'heure
les le bac 2001 pour ces jeunes du cned
parce que bon j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses plein de réglementer et le maine
libre dit libre effectivement on des
régimes un peu particulier par rapport
aux examens et il semblerait qu'il y ait
un problème par rapport aux jeunes qui
passeront bac de 8,21 pour ces jeunes dû
être réglementé qui je le rappelle sont
souvent des gens qui font des jeux à
domicile par exemple mais pour des
raisons de force majeure puisqu'ils ont
des problèmes de santé ou un univers de
handicap etc
et puis enfin je voudrais évoquer cette
charte ce contrat d'engagement
républicain qui est souvent très
sensibilité aussi puisque et les
associations la jeunesse on leur fait
encore quelque chose qui va poser des
problèmes à ses nombreuses associations
qui sont d'ailleurs deux de niveau de
subventions des pouvoirs publics et
divers ça va de la petite subvention
jusqu'à de très grosse somme de
subventions moi je pense que l'ia à une
charte d engagement réciproque qui
existe dans ce pays depuis 2001 qui a
été améliorée parfois et je penche des
fois c'est ce que je sais fendre l or
lors du débat qu'on puisse s'en tenir à
cette charte des engagements réciproques
tout temps bien entendu et tout en étant
un peu sévère vis-à-vis de ceux qui ne
respirait ne respectant pas cette charte
par rapport aux sanctions qui peuvent
être apportées mais qui devrait être
graduée et pas seulement laisser l
autorité administrative
voilà je remercie max brisson
alors jacques grosperrin d'accord merci
max et merci président oui parce que
tout je dois je dois a terminé en cas de
la proposition de loi
il a dit pauline gaillard chrysler qui
était député avant moi je voudrais faire
un témoignage voilà merci monsieur
ministre également de de me pardonner du
fait que je pourrais pas autour de la
réponse moi je vais vous dire que j'ai
chez moi j'ai apprécié les les droits de
l'enfant pas si je crois que c'est
jusqu'à important mais la seule
originalité l'école c'est cette fondue
l'éducation publique non plus trop le
séparatisme on comprendrait où je veux
arriver et confessionnels mais sur la
fraternité nationale est ce qui a été
fait depuis longtemps sur dans
l'histoire
c'était non pas d'une lutte contre la
foi mais en tout cas là contre la haine
parce que toute foi et respectable et
céline qui est mauvaise et je crois que
tout ce qui est arrivé aux nous la
laïcité l'a bien montré
lorsqu'on reprend émile littré sur le
sur sa conception de catholiques et son
suffrage universel il dit bien justement
que ceux qui adhèrent aux institutions
démocratiques
ce sont ceux qui justement ne vote pas
au moment les consignes clérical et le
problème à nous justement c'est les
réduire par tous les moyens éducatifs la
proportion des enfants musulmans selon
suffrage universel elles selon la notion
de littré et de réduire le séparatisme
confessionnel musulman et je crois que
le mot séparatistes c'est pas un mot qui
me gêne on l'a un peu espacées en tout
cas on a un peu laissé mis de côté parce
qu'on a eu peur on m'en donnait encore
chaque fois sur le même problème de
stigmatiser mais je crois que c'est pas
stigmatiser de dire des choses est
d'aider les jeunes justement à à se
construire
mais pour se construire ces on se
construire à travers une nation même le
mot nation l'un petit peu oubliée alors
que c'est pas un gros mot
je sais que vous l'oubliez pas mais
c'est vrai que la république elle a
donné à l'école justement là cette
notion transmettre cet héritage et à
tous ses enfants mais je voudrais vous
poser les trois questions la première
c'est sur le rôle des zips et des
espèces peu et c'est parce qu'on a
cliquez pendant très longtemps aux
enseignants qui l'ont redit d'ailleurs
aux élèves que l'histoire française et
colonial que l'impro sexistes qu'il
fallait déconstruire la culture qui
était porteuse des stéréotypes que la
culture est contre nature
donc en réalité je crois qu'il ya un
vrai problème on aura beau parler de
séparatisme là je crois qu'il ya un vrai
problème en france c'est un problème au
niveau de la formation
parce que la formation c'est pas
simplement la formation à la laïcité
mais c'est avant tout la formation sait
transmettre le savoir à la culture de
cette école qui éduque la deuxième
question c'est par rapport à limousis f
l'instruction en famille et moi ce qui
m'inquiète par rapport à ça c'est que si
certains n'ont pas la possibilité de le
faire
ils m'ont créé des écoles qui seront
sous contrat hors contrat ou son contrat
moi j'avais visité avec d'ailleurs sur
bernard miyet peut-être peut-être être
là et françoise laborde eu un lycée
alors on va le site et parce que souvent
on n'ose pas dire les mots mettre les
mots sur les choses mais je crois que
c'est important lycée averroès
on était rentrés par l'extérieur ce sera
plus facile que l'expliqué yeah yeah
président laffont on était rentrés par
par l'apport de sortir aussi rendu
compte qu'en réalité les garçons
n'étaient pas du tout avec les filles on
s'est rendu compte que il ya une belle
explication du directeur
et lorsqu'on a discuté avec les enfants
ont leur demander comment ça se passe et
les cours d'éducation physique une
vision bas on échappe à notre côté alors
que le directeur nous avaient dit qu'ils
étaient ensemble
lorsqu'on leur demandait est-ce que vous
qu'est ce que vous pensez le choix ah
ben c'est au programme monsieur mais
qu'est-ce que vous penchez pensée est ce
que ça existe et est ce que monsieur
c'était au programme les cours
d'éducation visite chacun de son côté je
pense que les spécialistes en parleront
peut-être eu certainement mieux que moi
aussi tout à l'heure mais je crois qu'on
m'en donne et si on n'a pas
ces possibilités de pouvoir contrôler
c'est un vrai problème parce qu'il ya
des collections sous contrat en réalité
qu'ils sont capables de faire des choses
dont on ne se rend pas compte
alors avant il y avait le déni il
déniche sic monsieur le ministre vous
n'êtes pas dans le déni
je le reconnais je vous en remercie et
puis enfin est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
imaginer plutôt des équipes mobiles
départementale alors ciconscription
irène ip r sous la forme d'aidés de ce
qui pourrait exister sous les formes de
la laïcité mais la laïcité et les
valeurs de la république en liaison avec
le second degré moi je pense qu'il ya
binôme fort à mettre en place entre lui
et les ip r pour qu'ils puissent
identifier et puis peut-être mieux
contrôler parce que la difficulté qu'on
se rend compte qu'on entend de partout
c'est dire oui mais c'est difficile on
n'arrive pas véritablement à pouvoir
contrôler ce qui se passe dans les
familles mais ce qui passe dans les
familles sont le contrôler mais vous
omettez moyens et met les moyens
c'est mettre en place ce qu'on pourrait
appeler ses équipes académiques avec des
déclinaisons départementales merci c'est
le ministe merci président remercie bat
temps de parole des groupes
max ne m'en voudra pas de le faire
attendre un peu pour respecter le sait
la règle voilà et est donc tombé dessus
merci monsieur le ministre et merci
monsieur le président où vous rejoins
sur le conte vous dites que évidemment
la république c'est l'école et la
centralité de l'école dans la république
on a un peu de mal à vous suivre quand
sur certains quartiers populaires on
peut évaluer qu'un élève en seine saint
denis
faire une année total de scolarité
surfant sur la totalité de sa scolarité
à cause de l'absentéisme du manque de
moyens dans certains collèges de
quartiers populaires notamment dans
l'académie de créteil où des
mobilisations sont encore en cours face
à cette situation donc malgré le rapport
la cour des comptes 2010 est ça continue
et puis globalement sur le sur le texte
qu'on étudie aujourd'hui il est clair
qu'ils frappent fort et il frappe plus
largement que sa cible initiale bon
alors les débats autour de l'instruction
en famille ont fait beau le texte tout
de même et aimer sa frappe tout de même
une liberté que vous avez appelé le vide
juridique
mais on a bien compris que y'avait pas
d'étude d'impact réel sur la
déscolarisation pour radicalisation
religieuse et que vous avez construit
cet article de loi tout de même pour
remettre en cause l'instruction en
famille sans avoir de données chiffrées
on avait interrogé dominique snapper du
conseil des sages a les cités qui a
aussi balayé l'intérêt d'avoir des
données chiffrées puisque comme vous
elle nous expliquer que effectivement le
une exception se justifie le fait de
produire un texte aussi large
alors moi je vous l'avais dit vous allez
renforcer les contrôles et mon collègue
vient de le dire aussi un besoin d'avoir
des équipes de contrôle renforcées on va
savoir quels sont les moyens que vous
allez mettre sur les contrôles réels de
l'instruction en famille et puis moi je
m'interroge quand même sur la complexité
d'évaluer un peu la proportionnalité de
cet encadrement très strict de
l'instruction en famille et les
objectifs poursuivis
est ce que c'est encore vraiment
proportionnelle par rapport à tout ça
avec une vision aussi vague du nombre
d'enfants concernés par la réalisation
évidemment que ça chaque enfant est un
enfant de trop mais si on remet en cause
l'ensemble de l'instruction en famille
c'est problématique voilà
céline brulin merci président monsieur
le ministre sur d'abord l'instruction en
famille
j'entends ce que vous dites qu'il ya
difficulté à faire un diagnostic chiffré
précis
il semblerait par exemple dans mon
département que même si c'est ça reste
des chiffres très marginaux
effectivement une progression et qu'il y
aurait un petit moment de cette
progression qui pourrait je parle
vraiment au conditionnel être ce corrélé
à l'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans est
ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on
constate partout ou pas et quelles
conclusions peut-on en tirer comme mes
collègues
quelles sont les capacités réelles à
contrôler ce qui se passe dans
l'instruction en famille vous pensez
pouvoir développer et puis si ses
enfants ses soixante deux mille enfants
qui sont aujourd'hui dans l'instruction
en famille allaient à l'école ou
irait-il est-ce qu'on a des projections
irait-il dans l'école publique qui reste
il dans l'école privée hors contrat ou
sous contrat est-ce qu'on a une idée un
peu plus précise de sa sur les
certificats médicaux de complaisance
moi j'ai presque un peu plus loin que ce
que le rapporteur la faune suggéré en
parlant de médecins disposant d'un
agrément pieds-noirs pardon désolé mais
il n'y a pas il n'y avait pas vraiment
de france dans ce que disait là ni pour
l'un ni pour l'autre absolument donc les
certificats de complaisance
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas aller plus
loin et que ce soit les médecins
scolaires qui les accordent
évidemment on voit où je veux en venir
ça voudrait dire qu'il faut
considérablement augmenté la médecine
scolaire dans ce pays
est ce que c'est une piste qui peut être
envisagée sur le sport très rapidement
je rejoins les inquiétudes qui ont été
exprimés sur ce contrat d'engagement
républicain et et sa traduction concrète
est ce que ça va impliquer pour les
clubs et état je pointe juste le moment
particulier dans lequel on est ou quand
même on va se retrouver avec un
mouvement sportif en sale état
compte tenu de l'épidémie des arrêts etc
et qui à mon
vie aussi cette dimension à prendre en
compte et puis enfin hier nous avons
auditionné jean pierre aubin que vous
vous dites à l'instant dont vous nous
rappeler un instant que vous l'avez
missionné et il a dit une chose qui
évidemment moi me parle et que ça vienne
de lui ça me parle davantage encore
c'est qu'en gros dans ce texte il manque
je vais peut-être pas utiliser les
termes exacts qui l'employait mais il
manque une dimension mixité sociale qui
est absolument essentiel tout le monde
en conviendra je pense pour lutter
contre les séparatismes et je dirais les
séparatismes de 12 ordres et donc sur
cet aspect de fond est ce qu'il ya des
réflexions qui peuvent aussi s'engager
sinon on ne fera que la moitié si ce
n'est même moins encore du chemin
merci françois patriat
c'est le président du ministre merci
compte tenu de la qualité des questions
qui ont été déjà posé qui rejoignent
pour partie les miennes je serais bref
pour dire que j'entends bien quelques
des tractions j'entends bien qu'il peut
y avoir quelques manques aujourd'hui
mais je voudrais quand même malgré tout
salué un texte qui trouvent un point d
équilibre entre la préservation des
libertés et la lutte contre le
séparatisme
il ya dans ce texte au delà des prises
en compte des problèmes de l'école qu'on
évoque ici ce matin beaucoup le problème
majorque qui n'avait pas été jusqu'à
présent athènes traiter et qui sont
traités dans ce texte et qui en font un
attaque je crois dont l'importance
n'échappe à personne donc qui va
susciter beaucoup de débats autres nous
ils sont bien légitimes
vous avez dit à plusieurs reprises
monsieur le ministre que ce projet de
loi était un texte pour et non un texte
contre et je le souligne mais aussi un
texte pour la république un texte pour
l'école et pour le droit à chaque enfant
à l'instruction
je crois qu'il était bon le souligner
pour en garder la tonalité majeur et qui
n'est pas celle des jets de dés
critiques qui peuvent être adressés à
grasse et à goûter bon nous avons
beaucoup débat mais bien sûr nous sommes
nous aussi tous nos collègues a
sollicité par les associations qui
défendent l'instruction des familles qui
évoque un régime d'interdiction avec des
exceptions plutôt qu'un régime
d'autorisation je crois que personne
aujourd'hui peut ne pas souhaiter un
contrôle plus strict de l'enseignement
des enfants à domicile
or ça passe bien entendu par un certain
nombre de mesures qui si on les écarte
et aujourd'hui on rendrait le texte
inopérant alors j'ai entendu déjà les
réponses que vous avez fait et certaines
questions posées par mes collègues qui
sont tout à fait légitime que je partage
par ailleurs mais peut-être comment
pouvez vous expliquer que nous ayons
deux ans par et reus qu'il ne l'ait pas
réussi à lutter contre le détournement
de la possibilité d'une instruction aux
familles quittent pourquoi est-ce qu'on
parce qu'on n'a pas cherché à le faire
parce que on était laxiste parce que on
ne voulait pas savoir qu'on est il des
contrôles qui sont aujourd'hui effectués
avez vous des chiffres des andonces
quand je pense que vous allez pouvoir
par avance un peu répandu mais est-ce
que vous avez quelques éléments
supplémentaires
quant au mouvement sportif et le contrat
d'engagement républicain on voit bien
que là aussi il existe des dérives un
chacun on a on est témoin dans son
territoire moi je l'étais à titre
personnel aussi on puisse demander
aujourd'hui un contrat d'engagement mais
paraît non pas la moindre des choses
mais un élément j'avais dire positif
dans le sens du texte de loi que nous
soutiendrons bernard fialaire il est
temps
oui merci vous prie de m'excuser donc
être en visio mais ministre qui s'occupe
aussi des sports et la commission
comprendra lille hier on avait l'arrivée
du paris nice dans mon territoire du
beaujolais et je me devais d'assister en
tant que sénateur du mot plus
sérieusement moi je voudrais revenir sur
ce point aussi des certificats médicaux
de complaisance quand on parle jeu comme
médecin et même comme médecin du sport
et qui a rédigé un mémoire sur les
certificats médicaux devrait rappeler
quand même que les certificats médicaux
qu'on dit de complaisance ils répondent
parfois à une véritable souffrance de
certains enfants vous savez à
l'adolescence en fonction de la
perception qu'on a de son corps ça fait
une véritable souffrance d'aller bien
quand on est couvert d'acné d'aller dans
une dans une piscine donc je crois qu'il
faut pas trop fantasmer sur ses
certificats en revanche elle détaille
même chose c'est un élève qui est
d'ailleurs on n'a pas du tout à marquer
je sache qu'un secret médical et
personne ne sait pourquoi les gens ou un
certificat médical de dispensant les
leçons bien que si la dispense du ru de
trois mois que le médecin scolaire doit
donner son avis et doit être consulté au
le prolonger est ce que c'est bien ça en
a aussi les moyens d'un médecin scolaire
et moi je plaide toujours ou quand même
une fusion de la médecine scolaire et de
la médecine de pmi des départements on
voit bien qu'une grande partie des
problèmes ont dit de santé sont si les
problèmes sociaux 1 dans le sens de la
santé oms c'est-à-dire bien-être
physique psychique et social et qu on
aurait tout à gagner à fusionner les
moyens des pmi et de la médecine
scolaire n'est pas en revenir à ces
certificats savait que les enseignants
peuvent quand même se faire un corps a
demandé aux élèves ils sont dispensés de
sport d'assister aux cours de venir ce
qui leur permet d'avoir un éveil de
regarder d'avoir même un jour une
appétence ou
ces matières dont on peut les priver par
ailleurs je crois à la force de
l'exemple
souvent ces enfants n'insiste pas pour
parce que c'est une confortable plus
facile de les mettre en études plus tôt
il était raccompagné quand je pense
qu'il faut parler à chacun son devoir
sur mon médecin ne pas permis de
certificats de complaisance on viendrait
pas en même temps aux enseignants
d'assumer ses élèves qui sont des élèves
qui va assister aux cours même s'il n'y
participent pas ou même de te disent pas
on revenir à la loi je partage ce qui
était dit par avec patriat d'une manière
générale 1 comme sénateur radical sadi
radicalement républicain j'attends de la
l'école de la république qu'elle soit
d'excellence keynes un exemplaire
qu'elle donne en lit à chaque famille il
y mettre ses enfants à chaque enfant d'y
aller et ça règlerait le problème pour
cela il faut des moyens
est ce que nous voulons vraiment faire
une priorité est-ce qu'on va vraiment
donner des moyens à cette éducation
nationale il réglerait une grande partie
des problèmes mais on n'aurait pas
mettre des enfants dans d'autres écoles
on n'aurait pas les dents faire
l'enseigné mois d'un site si on était
vraiment si on tout le monde était
convaincu de la qualité et qui est
proposé ses enfants
deuxièmement si le niveau de recrutement
mode depuis pas issus du monde de
l'enseignement un mais deux pics je vais
à interroger auditionné un peu ou des
établissements en moi je sais ce que tu
paies fait par exemple par les
principaux de collèges qui nice qui sont
consternés par les courriers qui
reçoivent des enseignants du primaire
qui leur envoient des enfants
donc il ya vraiment est-ce qu'on veut
leur faire une priorité
redonner des moyens monsieur le ministre
a à cette éducation nationale adam ont
ce qui est de la loi
tout ce qui va dans ce sens en dessous
tiendra mais il faudra passer peut-être
aussi un jour à la vitesse supérieure
le groupe s'est exprimé il ya trois
autres sénateurs qui veulent prendre la
parole vous propose de chaîner toutes
les questions en commençant par max
brisson
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur ministre pour cette audition
est aussi d'ailleurs pour la belle
soirée d'hier soir qui nous a installés
dans la sérénité avec lequel vous aurez
essayé de rester vous appelez de vos
voeux
nous avons auditionné hier matin jean
pierre aubert est ce qui nous a dit moi
m'a beaucoup ma beaucoup marqué la dcri
devant nous une menace réelle idée ou
d'une idéologie totalitaire
je crois qu'il faut nommer les choses
par leur nom qui est l'islamisme et qui
a pénétré profondément l'école et en
disant cela je n'accuse personne et
surtout pas vous je ne mets pas je ne le
dis pas que le pas de vague n'a pas
reculé
en fait un cancer qui s'est introduit
dans l'école et la l'école publique
ico quand même des coûts plus vite alors
c'est là le résultat ils ont un très bon
dit rien deux petites lâchetés cumulé
chacune est inoffensive mais c'est le
total de ses lâchetés qui pose le
problème de la loyauté puis je me suis
tanné et puis aussi ce qui est plus
grave pour le ministre éducation
nationale et une certaine connivence de
certaines élites intellectuelles y
compris dans l'île où l'on forme du
professeur de demain y compris dans la
déconstruction du concept même de
laïcité et dans le relativisme qui est
installée par rapport à cet assaut
principes républicains
donc on m'a prêté son maître simple dans
le texte sera examiné au j'ai vu
immédiatement ce qui concerne l école
privée hors contrat
j'ai vu immédiatement ce qui concernait
l'instruction à domicile j'ai eu
beaucoup plus de difficultés à voir en
quoi ce texte vous apporter des éléments
supplémentaires permettant de lutter
contre l'islamisme au coeur même de
l'école pub
où vu le nombre d'élèves le mal est
beaucoup plus absolu que partout
ailleurs
la deuxième question je n'aurai pas la
côte et que tu dois sérénité avec ce que
vous avez appelé de rappeler qu'en
joueurs vous indiquer au sénat que vous
aviez tous les outils nécessaires pour
lutter contre les dérives de
l'instruction que pourrait donner
éventuellement l'instruction en famille
il faudrait maintenant plutôt principe
précise et une liberté par la définition
des modalités de son exercice
je vous cite correspond une position que
nous pouvons pas dire que nous
partageons d'ailleurs parce que c'est un
fondement de l'état de droit et de la
démocratie il n'ya pas de liberté sans
cadres et vous avez raison
en revanche pensez vous qu une liberté
fondamentale s'exerce dans une
démocratie sous régime d'autorisation ne
pensez-vous pas davantage conforme à nos
principes républicains dont on parle
constamment de renforcer les contrôles
plutôt que de rentrer avec nos principes
républicains
nos valeurs républicaines fondamentales
vous insistez enfin sur le développement
de l'iref dans les départements leur
idéalisme islamistes se développe ce ne
le nie pas nous pourrons certainement le
préciser dans les années qui viennent
mais la vérité me semble consiste aussi
à dire ça davantage de chiffres puisque
nous avons dit nous côté ni de l'autre
qu'elle se développe aussi cette
instruction en famille sur bien d'autres
territoires et compris les territoires
ruraux et donc pour bien d'autres
réseaux qui ne peuvent ni être ignoré et
qui mérite qu'ils peuvent pas être
ignorées qui mérite autant d'attention
puisque chaque enfant compte cela compte
aussi et ceux ci bénéficient d'une élève
de qualité le plus souvent et pour des
motifs tout à fait légitime dont 4
sérénité je vous demande s'il ne serait
pas de meilleure politique d'entrer dans
une logique de renforcement des
contrôles de leur réactivité de leur
efficience y compris dans les quartiers
difficiles pour mettre hors d'état de
nuire
ceux qui s'éloignent république plutôt
que de jeter la suspicion sur tous je
vous remercie
laure darcos merci monsieur le président
monsieur ministre alors nous sommes pas
du tout coordonné avec max brisson mais
je vais juste en effet apporter un
témoignage supplémentaire
moi aussi je regrette véritablement
qu'on n'ait pas pu avoir des chiffres et
qu'on puisse classés entre guillemets
ces familles qui sont qui préfèrent en
effet inscrire leurs enfants à domicile
pourquoi parce que ce qu'a pu dire et je
même s'il apprécie énormément mon
collègue du même département francis
choix qui dit qui vous êtes donc
témoigner que c'était dans les quartiers
difficiles qu'on envoyait le plus moi
j'ai exactement l'un vers ce en termes
de témoignages j'ai reçu des centaines
et centaines de mails de parce qu'on est
à peu près 1000 milles enfants a priori
en instruction en famille en essonne
c'est ce que ces chiffres que nous a dit
le préfet moi j'ai beaucoup de 2,2 de
gens qu'ils soient sont dans les milieux
en effet le milieu rural pourquoi parce
que les problèmes de transport de rpi
c'est plus compliqué mais également moi
sur mon plateau de saclay j'ai des
familles
je veux dire presque un csp + qui ne
paraît enfin je veux dire par esprit non
non jamais voulu mettre leurs enfants
dans le privé mais ne trouve pas dans le
public
la rapidité ou en tout cas la
personnalisation d'instruction que
souhaitent leurs enfants mais ce sont
des familles qui à linverse de votre but
on recherchait ce que je trouve bien
évidemment honorable et on nous sommes
tous à vouloir entre guillemets lutter
contre eux
la déscolarisation notamment des petites
filles des jeunes filles mais ce sont
des familles qui sont très bien inséré
dans les communes qui en général
participe à toutes les associations
culturelles sportives et parents sont
impliqués dans en effet la vie souvent
communal donc en plus ce sont des
enfants qui sont extrêmement bien dans
leur peau et et bien et bien insérés et
cela ne comprennent pas en effet que
jette la suspicion sur eux ils
comprennent bien évidemment le but
recherché mais comme l'a dit max brisson
et d'autres collègues avant moi le fait
de ne parler que d'exception les gêne
énormément et donc moi aussi je suis
d'accord pour dire que est ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas à ce moment-là durci a
peut-être l'autorisation préalable
mais que ce soit une autorisation
naturel pour ces familles sur lesquelles
aucune suspicion de peut être jeté voilà
c'est tout j'aurais mangoné merci
président bonjour monsieur le ministre
est heureux de pouvoir échanger avec
vous sur ce sujet ô combien important
n'allez pas voir ici d'ailleurs dans mes
propos quelque chose d'autre chose que
constructif je vous le dis vis à vis de
vous que je respecte énormément et
entendez ne la prenez pas pour vous la
colère de moins en moins sourde qui
anime le sénateur que je suis de
l'essonne
je veux revenir au moment de cet ex sur
la temporalité qui est importante
4 septembre 2020 c'est le discours du
150e anniversaire prononcé par le
président de la république emmanuel
macron lydie des choses extrêmement sens
et très précise et à mon sens très
importante
le 2 octobre on est au discours par le
même président de la république de la
lutte contre le séparatisme qui rentre
dans notre qui revient dans notre
vocabulaire quotidien aux mureaux ils
prennent oms il prononce le discours aux
mureaux joli port de pêche de la région
ile de france
et puis le 16 octobre c'est le drame
absolu avec la décapitation de samuel
pâtit s'ensuit un hommage le 21 octobre
à la sorbonne hommage national et le 9
décembre 2020 c'est le projet de loi en
conseil des ministres on ne parle plus
de séparatisme heureusement on parle de
conforter les principes de la république
et c'est là dessus par rapport à la
remarque que j'ai à faire et à la
question que j'ai à vous poser en
essayant d'être le plus con si possible
c'est là dessus que je veux revenir
vous avez cité jules ferry tout à
l'heure je voudrais citer quelqu'un vous
appréciez aussi énormément albert camus
mal nommer les choses c'est ajouter au
malheur du monde
je suis frappée depuis le début de ce
travail sur ce texte de l'erreur
profonde gravissime faites par certains
commises par certains
peut-être par voilà une erreur simple
par d'autres c'est pas une erreur c'est
une volonté il y a une différence
fondamentale à mes yeux est pas comme
lien entre les valeurs de la république
et les principes de la république vous
même monsieur le ministre d'ailleurs
depuis le début sans y faire peut-être
attention plus que ça vous avez tout à
l'heure commis à mon sens le l'erreur de
distinguo puisque vous l'avez dit ce
sont des équipes valeurs de la
république
non ça ne peut pas être des équipes
valeurs de la république la laïcité n'a
jamais été une valeur de la république
c'est un principe républicain et c'est
la constitution de 58 qui nous le dit la
france est une république indivisible
laïque démocratique et sociale
le président de la république dans son
discours du 4 septembre ne dit pas autre
chose
ils placent directement la laïcité sous
le chef de la liberté
précisément
et donc dans cette loi qui est une
législation d'émotion et je n'aime pas
la législation d'émotion on cible
on cible précisément un groupe et ce
n'est pas un gros mot de le dire sans le
nommer sans le nommer et en se donnant
quelques alibis pour ne pas le nommer
et ça monsieur le ministre j'ai vraiment
du mal à l'accepter comme parlementaire
comme français et comme ayant en
héritage
c'est république que nous aimons tant et
vous et nous alors ensuite ça c'était
pour la remarque de fond j'ajoute quand
même pour faire la transition sur le
sport et je suis heureux que vous soyez
devenu avec un agenda qui n'était
certainement pas assez alors amassé
ministre des sports enfin nous avons un
ministre des sports et j'en suis heureux
même si je vois le ministère des sports
se réduire comme peau de chagrin
mais vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
l'olympisme et de la laïcité
oui la laïcité est un principe
extrêmement moderne et c'est pas pour
rien que le pays des lumières a
construit cette laïcité difficilement
mais il l'a construite et le baron
pierre de coubertin
de quelle nationalité était-il
l'olympisme aujourd'hui alors que c'est
un règlement
ce n'est pas une loi
l'olympisme aujourd'hui fait face aux
mêmes attaques de ceux qui veulent la
fin de notre république
ils veulent pas s'en séparer mes chers
collègues ne veulent pas s'en séparer du
tout ils en veulent la fin voilà
l'olympisme fait exactement face aux
mêmes problèmes que nous je parle des
footballeuses voile et je parle ok donc
sur ce sujet là oui l'olympique la
laïcité est extrêmement moderne mais
elle est extrêmement combattu également
et nous sommes les seuls tenants de
cette laïcité au monde
alors justement je voulais passer par le
sport très rapidement pour citer encore
une fois excusez moi albert camus
décidément qui en 57 disais tout ce que
je sais de la morale c'est au football
que je le dois je vais faire sourire mes
collègues ils savent que j'ai un
tropisme footballistiques pensez vous
deux secondes et demie monsieur le
ministre que ça soit ces fameux contrats
qui sont prévues par la loi qui vont
empêcher les prières islamistes dans les
vestiaires de football dans les couloirs
de vestiaires de football qui sont des
lieux publics
pensez vous que ces contrats vont
demander au club parce qu'on veut
responsabiliser les fédérations comme si
elle n'était pas responsabiliser les
fédérations mais avec quels moyens
vont-elles lutter contre des gens qui se
signent l'entente sur un terrain de
football
avec quels moyens vont-elles lutter
contre les gens qui vous ont font des
prières comme je lé vue sans pouvoir
agir par lâcheté par lâcheté car c'est
une lâcheté collective chers collègues
et on pourra prendre toutes les lois du
monde les rédiger du mieux possible
débattre entre nous pendant des heures
nous sommes à côté de la cible le
monsieur le ministre je sais qu'au fond
de vous je sais qu'au fond de vous vous
le savez parce que vous aimez la
république et vous aimez notre pays
comme on les aime tous ici mais du jour
où on va comprendre chers collègues que
la cible elle est là et qu'il s'agit pas
de taper ailleurs ce jour là j'espère on
en aura fini avec ses problèmes
voilà il ya deux autres collègues qui se
sont inscrits je n'en ai vraiment d'être
très rapide ce qui est important aussi
c'est d'écouter le ministre
donc sonia de la provôté et jean jacques
lozach si vous pouvez faire très rapide
oui merci beaucoup
surtout les en remercie monsieur le
ministre pour vos propos moi j'ai une
question très courte
la question des écrits pour les élèves
qui suivent la formation au cned se pose
puisque elle est nécessaire pour un
contrôle est ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
envisager pour les enfants qui ont cette
fois formation à domicile ou les enfants
qui sont les écoles hors contrat à
l'instar de ce qui se passe pour tous
les autres enfants pour évaluer leur
évolution matière d'acquis pédagogique
de participer aux évaluations
évaluations nationales de cp de c1 comme
tous les autres et d'organiser ce point
d'étape
parce qu'il me semble que considérer
qu'un point d'étape sera utile à la fin
du lycée ça paraît un peu moins pour
faire un constat
alors que si on faisait de façon
intermédiaire à ce moment là qu'il ya un
moment comme vous l'avez bien évaluer
vous même très important peut-être qu'on
pourrait reprendre pourrait accompagner
notamment les projets pédagogiques pour
que les enfants comble certains écarts
parce qu'en l'état actuel des choses on
ne sait pas où ils se situent par
rapport à ce sujet je vous remercie jean
jacques lozach
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le sport est donc concernée par
les articles 25 et 27 25 bis avec deux
nouveautés importantes dont la première
ce changement de régime
concernant le changement de modèle qu'on
sent dans les relations entre l'état ils
vous demandent sportive puisque l'on
passe d'un modèle de tutelle à modèle de
contrôle même si ça reste très très
théorique est la réalité beaucoup plus
nuancée que ça mais est ce que vous
pensez pas et on est un certain nombre à
penser que ce changement de relations
entre l'état événements sportifs ne
l'est pas davantage sa place dans la loi
sport qui arrive en débat dès la semaine
prochaine à l'assemblée nationale
et bientôt sénat plutôt que dans ce
texte concernant les principes de la
république
et puisque je parle de contrôle quel va
être son contenu on vivait être définies
par quatre décrets qui seront pris en
conseil d'état
mais à ce stade le mouvement olympique
et sportif se dit non associés aux
travaux préparatoires à ce qui va
devenir donc demain son contrôle par
l'état
on sait concerne la deuxième nouveauté
c'est à dire le contrat d'engagement les
publicains il faut savoir c'est vrai que
les éducateurs les intervenants dans les
clubs sont en situation d'attenté d'un
certain nombre de référents
d'indicateurs pour intervenir
éventuellement face à certains types de
comportements et je voudrais savoir si
ledit de la laïcité dans le sport
alors qui est réforme c'est vrai est-ce
qu'il ne mérite pas d'ores et déjà
d'être d'être dépoussiéré et puis enfin
une bonne question un petit peu annexes
mais qui concerne quand même le sport
scolaire c'est le pass'sport jour des
savoir où on en est au niveau des
arbitrages après la la déclaration très
importante du président de la république
merci monsieur mini jeux vous aviez
quelques pages de questions donc
c'est la parole pour y apporter les
réponses très bien merci beaucoup
monsieur le président je vais donc
répondre dans l'ordre évidemment des
différentes questions d'abord donc les
questions de madame la sénatrice annie
guillon le d'abord sur le rôle des
collectivités locales dans l'instruction
en famille ça fait partie finalement des
choses qui se sont élaborées avec le
temps et qui méritait elle a aussi une
forme d'actualisation comme chacun sait
le maire un rôle
effectivement et il a mal à sa triste
vous l'avez vous l'avez rappelé les mets
ont un rôle très important mais c'est un
rôle qui a forcément ses limites
et d'ailleurs c'est des limites qu'il
rencontre aujourd'hui dans l'état du
droit actuel
parce que d'abord toutes les mairies ne
sont pas sur ce sujet comme sur d'autres
dans les mêmes avec les mêmes moyens
humains et les mêmes capacités selon
leur taille selon leur richesse pour
faire les choses ce qui est prévu c'est
de s'assurer que les familles ont les
moyens requis pour assurer l'instruction
en famille mais cela reste quelque chose
d'assez d' assez vagues assez sommaire
et ne peux et ça ne peut guère ça peut
difficilement être envisagé que ça aille
plus loin il normal que ce soit l'état
et de manière plus homogène possible qui
soit dans cette situation de contrôle en
lien avec les maires parce que par
ailleurs les maires sont dans une
situation évidemment particulièrement
adapté pour signaler les problèmes et
participer à la logique de contrôle
donc c'est la logique dans laquelle nous
sommes c'est une logique aussi qui peut
dans les temps à venir associer
davantage des conseils départementaux
aux enjeux je pense en particulier à ce
qui se passe au titre de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance et et de la connaissance
qu'ont les administrations
départementales de mai institutions
départementales de des enjeux s'agissant
des élèves inscrits au cned
vous m'avez au cadre réglementé donc
vous même si ce n'est pas complètement
relié à au projet de loi que je vous
présente mais vous êtes 3 avoir souhaité
m'interpella dessus donc je vais
répondre bien bien volontiers ne pas me
dérober par rapport à cette question là
vous avez fait un peu l'exposé de la
situation et profiter pour mon tour
d'une certaine façon nous poser une
question d'abord nous sommes donc dans
une année de réforme du baccalauréat de
vous se parachève la réforme dont le
principe est d'avoir en temps normal une
part de contrôle terminal à une part de
contrôle continu 60% de contrôle
terminal 40% de contrôle continu
j'assume totalement cette mixité des
deux épreuves puisque il ya des vertus
aux deux nature des preuves une le
contrôle terminal qui est objective
peut-être davantage l'autre qui
encourage le travail continu des élèves
et on voit bien l'intérêt des d2 des
deux formules l'an dernier l'année
scolaire dernière 2019 2020 a été hors
du commun et jusqu'à une date proche du
mois de juin il était difficile
d'établir dans quelle condition pourrait
se dérouler vent tuellement le
baccalauréat il a été décidé de faire il
était décidé tardivement il ne pouvait
pas en être autrement que ce serait par
le contrôle continu et donc à ce moment
là il était normal
s'assurer qu'aucun élève de france ne
serait lésé par cette décision
forcément un peu soudaine que j'avais
prédit d'ailleurs avec d'autres après de
très nombreuses concertations
c'était totalement exceptionnel et là
aussi assumé comme tel
c'est d'ailleurs le signe que évidemment
en aucun cas je ne veux et ne
accepterait même de discrimination
injustifiée entre des des élèves venus
de différents horizons je réponds qu
utiliser une expression il n'y a que des
élèves de france dans une situation
comme ça fait pas de distinction c'était
une situé 6 y ont presque je dirais
d'urgence la situation de l'année 2020
21 est totalement différente
nous sommes en situation d'anticiper et
qu'elle fait comme évolution des règles
du jeu j'ai simplement dit qu'au mois de
mars
il était très difficile d'envisager des
épreuves telles que prévues dans cette
nouvelle épreuve d' enseignement de
spécialité et que puisqu'il en était
ainsi nous le transformions contrôle
continu et j'essayais de le dire avec le
plus d'avancé possible je le dis au mois
de janvier de façon à ce que personne ne
soient piégés et que les élèves les
l'immense majorité des élèves c'est à
dire ceux qui sont dans l'enseignement
public et dans l'enseignement privé sous
contrat puisse travailler entre janvier
et juin dont connaissant parfaitement
les règles du jeu qu'ils sont que ce
sera le contrôle continu pour ces
épreuves et je maintiens le contrôle
terminal pour la philosophie et le grand
oral
les élèves qui sont dans les écoles hors
contrat et dans les équipes sondant le
cned rêve dit réglementés sont dans deux
situations différentes
chacun dans leur catégorie d'ailleurs
par rapport à ça tout contrôle continu
suppose que nous puissions nous assurer
tout simplement des deux conditions
équitables de réalisation ce n'est pas
parfaitement le cas des élèves qui sont
au cadre réglementé puisque le la
manière dont ils font leurs épreuves
dans correspondant aux enseignements de
spécialité se passe à la maison du parc
est donc très différente de ce qui se
passe pour des élèves qui allant à
l'école tous les jours vont fonder des
devoirs sur table
c'est pourquoi s'agissant des élèves du
cned réglementée on a tout simplement
établi là la règle qui était prévu sauf
que les choses se passent au mois de
juin pour lui de se passer au mois deux
mois de mars ce qui me surprend et vous
savez qu'on a un débat symétrique avec
les élus les élèves des écoles hors
contrat puisque là aussi pour les élèves
hors contrat comme nous n'avons pas
d'inspection des écoles hors contrat sur
le plan pédagogique
nous assurons pas d'une garantie de
qualité du contrôle continu et ce
faisant la ce qui a été décidé pour eux
c'est que les épreuves qui n'ont
vraiment avait lieu en mars tout
simplement ont lieu en juin
alors certes ça crée trois situations
différentes mais parce que ya trois
conditions d'exercice des choses qui
sont différentes la question que nous
pose collectivement nous les français
c'est que j'ai parfois du mal à
comprendre qu'on on se
on se scandalise du fait d'avoir à
passer un contrôle terminal plutôt qu'un
contrôle continu lorsque je prends ces
décisions sont des décisions pratiques
c'est pas des décisions qui avantage ou
qui désavantagent n'y a pas un avantage
intrinsèque apprécié contrôle continu ou
à passer le l'épreuve terminale donc je
ne voudrais pas que l'épisode de l'an
dernier finisse par instillé dans les
esprits que j'aurai une situation plus
favorable parce qu'on serait en contrôle
continu que en contrôle terminal et je
me souviens très bien d'ailleurs que les
dernières quand on a installé contrôle
continu pour tous certaines voix que je
pouvais comprendre d'ailleurs protesté
en disant on aurait aimé passer le
contrôle terminal et après tout ils
avaient en partie raison il se trouve
que cas de force majeure nous empêcher
de le faire donc
j'entends les critiques et les
protestations et d'ailleurs je reste
très ouvert pour en parler de manière
objective et il n'y a pas autre chose
que l'intérêt général à rechercher dans
ces cas là mais ce que je ne voudrais
pas c'est que s'installe dans l'esprit
public l'idée que je suis défavorisés
parce que on ne m'a pas accordé le
principe de passer le contrôle continu
j'en profite pour dire que j'ai toujours
été attaché au contrôle terminal
parfois on a soupçonné de vouloir
installer le contrôle continu absolue et
en finir avec les examens finaux
ça n'a jamais été ma philosophie je les
ai d'ailleurs toujours dit et je crois
ce que nous démontrons dans cet épisode
ou avec le plus de rigueur possible nous
essayons d'avoir quelque chose qui soit
juste mais le fait que vous ayez à
passer aux épreuves en juin plutôt qu'en
mars et en aucun cas quelque chose qui
vous laisse le fait que les élèves des
écoles hors contrat soit dans une
situation différente des autres n'a rien
de nouveau
c'est ce qu'on doit assumer quand on va
dans une école hors contrat et bien
entendu je leur souhaite à tous la
pleine réussite et
et a aucune volonté de nuire à qui que
ce soit donc il ya une forme de dérive
je pense dans le raisonnement ceci étant
c'est un débat qui est sûre qui est sur
la table
peut-être des arguments que j'ai pas su
comprendre je reste à l'écouté de d2 de
ce qui selon les avocats de des des
élèves du club réglementé ou des élèves
des écoles hors contrat mais je vais
déjà leur assurer un de ma totale
bienveillance de du fait que bien
entendu le système retenu en aucun cas
ne valait 9 à l'elysée et qui à bien des
sujets sur lesquels des élèves peuvent
se trouver dans des situations
différentes
du fait qu'ils sont que tel choix a été
fait du mode de scolarisation donc voilà
ce que je voulais répondre sur cette
question je suis certain que il y aura
encore d'autres débats sur ces sur ces
enjeux c'est peut-être l'occasion d'une
réflexion aussi sur les écoles hors
contrats et sur finalement on peut être
un contrôle pédagogique plus important
qui permettrait de s'assurer d'un
contrôle continu
d'un contrôle continu garantie pour tous
en tout cas
je voulais répondre à cette question et
plusieurs d'entre vous de composer
ensuite troisième ensuite pardon il ya
eu les interventions de monsieur
sénateur bailly le
vous m'avez demandé donc justement
pourquoi on n'était pas sur un régime
d'autorisation aussi pour les écoles
hors contrat c'est inédit que vous aviez
défendu dans au moment de la de la loi
gatel vous l'avez vous l'avez rappelé il
n'y a pas le dire et faire une symétrie
du raisonnement il ya pas une
supériorité intrinsèque de la du régime
de déclaration et le régime
d'autorisations j'entends l'argument
consistant à dire c'est étonnant
finalement vous avez à jim
d'autorisation pour l'instruction en
famille un régime de déclaration pour
les écoles hors contrat alors que d'un
certain bon sens pourrait laisser penser
que le la situation de façonnerait plus
exigeants encore pour une école que pour
un individu majorité c'est plus exigeant
c'est à dire que le régime de
déclaration qui existe un régime qui
oblige à fournir sa tante de documents
est désormais d'ailleurs dans le cadre
de la loi grenelle ii d'éléments qui
sont qui sont exigeants donc je crois
d'ailleurs et ça vaut pour tout ce qu on
va se dire sur l'instruction en famille
que faut pas non plus fait utiliser les
mots et les dispositifs c'est à dire que
des autorisations ou déclarations ne
partent pas en soi une exigence
supplémentaire et que si forte ce qui ce
qui est important pour le pour les
écoles hors contrat c'est le changement
que donc on leur demande au moment de la
déclaration des documents qui qu'ils
soient qui permettent d'attester de la
qualité ce qui passera ensuite dans ce
que nous avons fait il ya aussi l'idée
que les choses doivent se passer
seulement au moment de la déclaration
mais qu'après il ya tout un continuum de
vérification qui doit avoir lieu tout au
long de l'existence de l'établissement
vous m'avez interroge aussi vous même
sur le club est réglementée j'ai répondu
vous m'avez interrogé aussi sur la
charte d engagement réciproque comme
d'autres sénateurs
on fait pour dire que là aussi ce que je
dois vous répondre c'est que là là bien
en tant que la loi enfin les
dispositions qui me concerne dans cette
loi concerne mon champ de compétence
dans cette loi sont ne prétende n'ont
aucun des cas être l'alpha et l'oméga de
ce qu'il y à faire et je voudrais
vraiment là aussi plusieurs questions
avait cet angle-là redire que cette loi
est une étape très importante de nature
législative par définition d'une
problématique générale pour laquelle des
mesures ont déjà été prises
d'autres mesures seront prises au aussi
dans dans l'étonnant étant futur est ce
que la charte d'engagements réciproques
pas résoudre tous les problèmes c'est
aussi la question du sénateur données
bien sûr enfin admettons le bien sûr que
oui ça ne résout pas toutes les preuves
et que notamment les grands enjeux ils
sont après dans dans le nom l'action au
quotidien des fonctionnaires ou des who
des responsables et c'est cela que nous
mettons en route et la loi elle envoie
aussi un signal politique dans ce sens
nous appuierons sur cette loi pour
l'évolution d'un certain nombre d' un
certain nombre de choses le domaine du
sport est à la fois comparables est
différent au domaine de l'éducation les
libertés ne sont pas les mêmes c'est pas
la même chose pour les adultes et pour
les pour les mineurs et ainsi de suite
d'où l'importance de l'adaptation à
chaque que ce sport à chaque si à chaque
à chaque situation
il ya des traditions dans certains
sports ça rejoint aussi certaines de vos
questions que fait de se signer après un
but je suis pas sûr que ce soit ça que
nous poursuivons à travers de cette loi
dont nous aurons du mal sinon
donc en revanche le fait que certains
équipements publics soient utilisés de
façon sauvage et d'une certaine façon
conçus pour qu'un certain prosélytisme
pour réaliser des frayeurs public ça
c'est un problème est en effet nous
devons nous devons y travailler donc il
ya à la fois une lettre et un esprit de
la loi
la led permet de résoudre des problèmes
mais certainement pas tous les problèmes
l'esprit est le signal que le présent
dans le public a envoyé tout
particulièrement lors du discours d des
mureaux il a aussi pour répondre par
avance à quelque chose que le sénateur
audois des a dit tout à l'heure on peut
faire toutes les critiques que l'on
souhaite à cette loi mais ne l'appelant
palois d'émotion
elle est aux comptes rencontre et on lui
a fait le reproche inverse beaucoup que
n'ai-je entendu sur la tente qu'il y
avait du discours des mieux et il ya eu
de la préparation et de cette
préparation
nous avons réagi à aucun fait divers
spécifique pour faire ça en faisant
cette loi que après on est tenu compte
d'événements dramatiques comme
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit pour tel ou
tel article c'est tout à fait juste
et c'est normal mais nous n'avons pas
déclenché de façon artificielle
processus législatif à partir d'un
événement créé en émotions nous avons un
travail de fond qui s'élabore depuis de
nombreux mois et qui débouche sur un
certain nombre de dispositions à mes
yeux cohérentes entre elles par rapport
à ce qu'a dit le sénateur grosperrin
dont certains pointent aussi ont
coïncidé avec d'autres interventions
suivantes notamment celle du sénateur
brisson le
il m'a interrogé sur la le sénateur
brisson aussi sur la sueur finalement
les enjeux de formation des professeurs
s'agissant de la laïcité et les propos
de certains européens comme du sénateur
brisson ont consisté à s'inquiéter des
logiques de déconstruction de la
république et de la laïcité
porté par certains milieux académiques
éventuellement en espèces
alors que plusieurs éléments de réponse
à cela d'abord la mission confiée à
l'inspecteur général honoraire jean
pierre robin est justement fait pour
regarder ce sujet nous avons aussi
actuellement un travail fait avec les
aspects je reçois au moment de leur
nomination chaque directeur ou
directrice dink paix de france pour
faire le point sur l'ensemble des enjeux
dont dont celui ci de façon à ce que
nous sachions avoir un système de
formation des professeurs qui tire le
plein bénéfice et du cadre universitaire
et du du lien avec l'éducation nationale
il ya une particularité des xp dans
notre système
ce sont d'une certaine façon des écoles
professionnelles dont les étudiants vont
par définition être embauchés par un
seul employeur qui s'appelle l'éducation
nationale et cet employeur a quelque
chose à dire sur la formation qui est
attribué par ailleurs elle se passe
c'est un choix qui a été fait il ya
maintenant une vingtaine d'années dans
un cadre universitaire et ce cadre
universitaire doit signifier excellence
de la forme l'excellence de la formation
en particulier
c'est le sens de aussi de certaines
dispositions de la loi pour l'école de
la confiance que d'avoir cadrer ces
différents éléments
nous sommes donc très attentifs et
j'attends beaucoup des conclusions de
jean pierre robin haase qu' il y ait un
enseignement
je dirais volontariste claire homogène
aussi sur les valeurs de la république
et les principes de la république
ainsi que sur la laïcité dans la
formation initiale aussi dans la
formation continue des professeurs alors
évidemment la deuxième dimension de la
question élec
mais ce qui apparaît aujourd'hui
finalement des idéologies en oeuvre qui
qui conduisent à cette forme de
déconstruction de la laïcité voilà
répondre la réponse à vous et je suis je
crois qu il est bien connu que je que
j'ai que je regarde ce sujet en face
très fortement dans le cadre du débat
d'idées bien normal mais aussi dans le
cadre d'une forme d'explicitation des
tenants et des aboutissants de ce qui se
joue j'ai fait référence tout à l'heure
aux états unis et au fait que d'autres
modèles de société se propose et nous il
est clair que est gelée largement dit
que aujourd'hui il ya toute une série
d'idées qui se présente très clairement
comme étant des idées de déconstruction
de la pensée des lumières de la deûle à
l'idée républicaine qui en est résultée
et au fond de ce qui fonde l'école de la
république enchaîne les gens qui pensent
comme ça doivent l'assumer mais c'est
vrai que c'est parce que nous désirons
comme enseignement pour nos professeurs
nous ne désirons pas non plus que nos
professeurs enseignent aux élèves que la
france n'est pas un état aimable qu' il
y aurait un racisme d'état et toutes
sortes
le but visé qui sont extrêmement
dangereuses pour l'avenir de notre pays
et donc c'est évidemment
quelque chose qui doit être explicite et
alors il ya des choses qui relève du
débat d'idées c'est bien normal
j'ai beaucoup entendu parler des
libertés académiques lors de polémiques
récentes
en effet il faut de la liberté
académique et justement cette liberté
académique doit s'accompagner de de
clarté et aussi du fait que au nom de la
liberté académique et justement pas de
pression sur ceux qui ne pensent pas
comme les porteurs de cette idéologie de
déconstruction donc chaude nous devons
être attentifs à ça nous devons renouer
avec ce qui a fait la force de l'école
de la république c'est à dire le fait
que dans la formation des enseignants il
y avait non seulement des enjeux de
savoir par exemple les professeurs
d'écoles primaires de très bonne
maîtrise de la transmission des savoirs
fondamentaux mais aussi de transmission
de valeurs
on a parlé des huit chars noirs de la
république parce que c'est des personnes
qui portaient chevillée au corps
la pensée républicaine et la
transmettait aux enfants tout en
respectant totalement
ce que l'enfant avait comme valeurs
transmises par la famille les deux
peuvent parfaitement aller ensemble et
ça évidemment ça fait écho avec ce que
nous pouvons dire sur l'instruction en
famille le sénateur européen va aussi
demander s'il ne pouvait pas y avoir des
équipes à l'échelle départementale at il
dit pour la mise en oeuvre de tout ça on
a été je peux répondre oui à cette
question c'est justement ce que nous
programmons c'est à dire à partir
d'ailleurs de l'équipe qui parfois
peuvent déjà existé ou en tout cas de
deux personnes qui sont qui peuvent être
aujourd'hui dédié à ces enjeux d'étoffé
complètement les équipes pour que là
aussi même en anticipation de la mise en
oeuvre de la loi qui serait à partir de
septembre 2022
à voir dès l'année 2021-2022 des équipes
qui peuvent être sur le terrain et
accomplir le travail
j'ai dit tout à l'heure qui avait
l'esprit et la lettre de la loi et qu'il
y avait aussi le facteur humain et les
les équipes dédiées c'est le sens de ce
que l'on de ce que nous allons faire sur
les questions posées par monsieur le
sénateur dessus lors vous avez commencé
par une observation sur finalement les
inégalités concrètes de terrain
qui sont à regarder au moins autant que
les enjeux que visées par la loi hope
être que d'accord avec vous sur ce point
est d'ailleurs il a été fait référence
aussi à ce que jean pierre robin avait
dit là dessus le présent la république
aussi a été très clair sur ces questions
aussi bien dans le discours des mureaux
qu'ultérieurement
nous devons avancer sur deux jambes il
ya un sujet de mixité sociale un sujet
de travail sur tout simplement l'égalité
réelle
et puis d'autre part c'est un sujet sur
les valeurs et les deux choses vont
ensemble on ne doit jamais opposée cela
vous avez cité les difficultés de la
seine saint denis
telles qu'elles avaient été parfois
mises en lumière par là par un rapport
de la cour des comptes et d'autres
rapports qui ont suivi je tiens à dire
qu'en matière d'éducation prioritaire
jamais je le dis et je suis prêt à
augmenter autant qu'il nous faudra
surtout être jamais autant n'a été fait
que sous ce quinquennat
la mesure la plus emblématique c'est
évidemment le dédoublement des classes
de cp et de ce1 ce2 aujourd'hui avec en
plus le dédoublement des grandes
sections plus de trois cent vingt mille
élèves qui sont concernés au moment que
je joue je vous parle
chaque année le b le département de
france qui bénéficient le plus de cette
mesure c'est la seine saint denis
de même les primes vrai plus pour
attirer des professeurs son second était
de porter à 2000 et oddo 1000 euros à la
rentrée dernière
c'est là encore le département de seine
saint denis qui est le premier
bénéficiaire donc je suis vraiment bien
passé pour savoir qui a encore beaucoup
à faire mais mais je ne souhaite pas
qu'on dise qu'il y aurait une sorte
d'oubli de ce côté là il ya au contraire
de du volontarisme avec après des
difficultés de terrain que personne
n'ignore donc votre mais votre question
centrale était pardon sur finalement la
disproportion éventuel entre cette
réforme est la cible affichée et nous
avons
beaucoup de questions qui tournent
autour de cet enjeu et je prends
évidemment cette question très au
sérieux alors qu'il ya deux catégories
de réponse vous là vous en avez rappelé
une vous avez peut-être semblait ne pas
approuver mais je l'appelle me paraît
fondamental c'est que quel que soit le
nombre d'enfants concernés
c'est important et ça je pense que en
matière de droits de l'enfant on devrait
à mon avis que d'accord avec ça ensuite
c'est vrai je l'ait reconnu à plusieurs
reprises encore aujourd'hui le
quenouille que les qu'il est très
difficile de cerner le phénomène
aujourd'hui mais personne ne saurait le
sous-estimer et encore une fois
donnons-nous des rendez-vous d'avenir si
je puis dire
c'est important d'avoir le sens du temps
du temps non sur ces questions vous
verrez eux
dans un an dans deux ans dans trois ans
le fruit de l'action qui auraient été
menées à la faveur de cette loi et
personne ne peut dire aujourd'hui qu'il
n'ya pas un phénomène
premièrement de développement
l'instruction en famille ça c'est un
fait les deuxièmes à l'intérieur de ce
phénomène de radicalisation et et de ses
parties de séparatisme avec des enfants
qu'ils ont dès le plus jeune âge sont
formés finalement à se séparer du commun
se séparer de ce qui fait que l'on se
retrouve ensemble lors saf saf et la
transition avec les questions posées
ensuite part à mme la sénatrice brulin
puisque vous me demandez si d'abord la
première question de savoir si
l'instruction à faire l'augmentation
partis flamands forte tout dernièrement
de l'instruction en famille correspond à
l'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans aura
été l'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans
explique en effet une partie du
phénomène
environ la moitié mai mais reste l'autre
moitié et même sur cette moitié là le de
toutes les façons ça nous dit bien que
justement lorsque l'on a fait
l'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans pour
travers de l'école pour de la loi pour
l'école de la confiance on pointe et
bien un problème tout de même c'est à
dire le fait que le ce qui se passe pour
un enfant entre 3 et 6 ans était
essentielle et que l'école maternelle
jouent un rôle fondamental de
socialisation et d'épanouissement pour
l'enfant et que vouloir une fois que
l'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans et
prononcé maintenir les l'enfant dans
l'instruction en famille et une
responsabilité particulière prise par la
famille qui mérite de ne pas être dans
un angle mort de nos approches autrement
dit nous devons vérifier que cela se
passe bien parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'un enfant cas pas été à l'école
jusqu'à l'âge de 6 ans peut arriver à 6
ans à l'école avec déjà des retards très
difficile à attraper par exemple en
matière de de voter de vocabulaire
vous avez posé ensuite une question très
difficile parce qu'elles relèvent de la
prospective qui est où iront les enfants
s'ils ne vont plus en l'instruction en
famille alors je
il est clair que nous devons
inciter à ce que ce soit dans l'école
publique locale fortiori à l'école
primaire où c'est en général pas si loin
du domicile souvenant certains dans
certains territoires ruraux
bien entendu il s'agit aussi d'une
liberté des familles est ce que nous
préservons et même conforté dans cette
loi c'est encore une fois les quatre
possibilités mais je rappelle que
lorsque nous avons fait des
démantèlements de structures comme par
exemple celle de grenoble donc à
laquelle je faisais référence tout à
l'heure le
cela s'accompagne d'une injonction à
scolariser quand la scolarisation n'a
pas eu cette injonction par définition
se fait dans une école publique locale
mais j'espère que dans l'immense
majorité des cas nous n'en serons pas
nous n'en arriverons avec les parents
tout simplement ouvrant des formules qui
leur plaisent nous ne sommes pas dans
une logique de d'injonction nous sommes
dans des logiques de liberté
et c'est l'occasion de le rappeler vous
avez demandé si les certificats médicaux
qui sont une des problématiques
soulevées aujourd'hui peut voir et être
fait par les médecins scolaires avant
c'est vrai que ça ça change ça
surchargerait beaucoup la barque alors
même que comme vous l'avez noter
vous-même les médecins scolaires
manquent
donc je ne pense pas ça ne peut pas être
la piste à court terme en tout cas
rappelons que tout ce que nous faisons
la matière y compris les conclusions que
nous tirons du rapport des inspecteurs
généraux se fait avec le conseil de
l'ordre en lien avec le conseil de
l'ordre des médecins et que sont
d'ailleurs l'ensemble de nos sujets
médicaux et sanitaires
ce que nous recherchons actuellement
c'est justement le décloisonnement
maximum entre la médecine scolaire et la
médecine de ville et les la médecine en
général notamment la coopération des pmi
pour pour avec l'école primaire
vous avez fait aussi référence aux
difficultés du monde sportif dans la
période actuelle
si j'ai bien compris la question c'est
un peu au fond est ce que vous leur
ajouter pas un problème de plus je crois
enfin moi je pense de façon générale sur
la crise que nous traversons que la
résilience dont tout le monde fait
preuve et toutes les institutions
s'efforce de faire preuve dans la
période actuelle prépare des
renaissances futur et que d'un mâle peut
naître un bien et je pense beaucoup à
cela sur plusieurs sujets en ce moment
ça en fait partie
le fait que vous ayez constitue
désormais un ministère de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
en pleine crise que resserre toute une
série de liens entre les acteurs la
solidarité vis-à-vis de l'état et des
acteurs publics vis-à-vis du monde
sportif s'est accentué à la faveur de
cette crise il ya une forme de
bienveillance vis-à-vis du sport qui est
très forte bien sûr peut pas compenser
tous les problèmes qui existent qui sont
nombreux mais qui crée un état d'esprit
que je considère comme très favorable
pour la suite et qui je pense si vous si
on faisait une comparaison avec d'autres
pays européens montre que me pays très
attentif par ces deux institutions
publiques à la à ce que le sport sorte
non diminué et même renforcé de la
période actuelle et pourquoi pas un peu
transformés aussi d'ailleurs pas
seulement par cette loi mais par deux
par d'autres éléments
pourquoi je pensais qu'on a actuellement
un dialogue très positif avec le monde
sportif et je fais le la relation avec
des questions qui ont été posées par par
d'autres que que vous ensuite
puisque on m'a demandé si les
dispositifs passeport ce j'observe fait
quelques questions qui sont pas liées
totalement la grue mais c'est un peu
normal mais en tout cas s'agissant du
dispositif passeport
il a vocation à être opérationnel pour
la rentrée prochaine avec un travail
justement qui est fait à forte dimension
sociale mais aussi qui va comme cubes
dont l'un des principes et non seulement
de traverser la crise pour aider les
clubs à survivre financièrement mais
aussi à créer des habitudes
d'inscription au club
au delà de la crise sanitaire dans notre
pays comme le sénateur dessus vous avez
insisté sur l'enjeu de mixité sociale en
citant le en citant jean pierre robin
donc je suis d'accord je rappelle
d'ailleurs qu'en ce moment même et
parfois cela fait couler de l'encré si
nous travaillons à paris
avec le recteur de paris sur
renforcement de la mixité sociale dans
les établissements scolaires à paris ce
qui est là aussi un gros dossier qui
finalement n'a pas été pris à bras le
corps depuis très nombreuses années et
qui qui suppose tout un travail pour
requalifier certains établissements
scolaires à paris
mais je suis très persuadé que nous
allons arriver à avoir finalement une
plus grande homogénéité de la qualité
des établissements dans paris et de la
sécurité aussi est débouchée ainsi sur
finalement le fait de tirer vers le haut
l'ensemble des établissements alors
c'est pareil est assez emblématique de
non mixité sociale parfois dans certains
endroits
c'est cela que nous pouvons changer sur
les questions posées par le sénateur
françois patriat sur sur ce tacle
d'avoir merci pour ce qu'il a dit en
introduction d'avoir appelé je crois
qu'on peut dire c'est que c'est un beau
texte d' équilibre
rappelons que nous l'avons mis dans le
sillage de la loi de 1905 et de son état
d'esprit
c'est à dire justement celui de
l'équilibré celui de la liberté
merci d'avoir rappelé aussi cette
formule que j'utilise en effet souvent
parce qu'elle me paraît essentielle et
je pense qu'elle j'espère en tout cas
qu'il transparaît dans ce que je vous
dis c'est un texte pour est pas un texte
contre et effectivement il a par exemple
sur ce qu'on vient dire sur le sport il
s'agit de renforcer les acteurs et pas
de lait en aucun cas de les brimer ou de
les baisers certainement pas
alors pourquoi pas la question posée par
le sénateur pour le président patriat
c'est pourquoi n'at-on pas réussi à
lutter contre le détournement de
l'instruction en famille précédemment
c'est vrai que quantitativement
l'instruction en famille est restée
longtemps marginal ville pas
relativement au nombre d'élèves en
france
deuxièmement que l'existence du cned
donner un sentiment de contrôle de la
situation
d'autant plus que bien il y avait une
forme de deux coïncidences entre le
sujet les problèmes de santé des élèves
ça n'est plus le cas et désormais les
élèves ayant des problèmes de santé sont
minoritaires dans dans ce qu'est
l'instruction en famille donc il ya
clairement eu un
un système de contrôle qui était adaptée
à une situation antérieure laquelle à
laquelle a changé mais le système de
contrôle est resté le même
d'où la nécessaire adaptation
aujourd'hui et puis le travail sur le
facteur humain c'est-à-dire ces équipes
n'ont dont j'ai parlé
merci aussi d'avoir souligné les
caractéristiques du contrat d'engagement
et publics inquiets qui va être le socle
de ce qu'on va faire en matière sportive
sur les questions posées par monsieur le
sénateur fialaire le donc j'ai bien pris
note des observations liminaire compris
sur les certificats médicaux je sais à
quel point c'est juste il faut être là
dessus d'un grand pragmatisme c'est bien
pour ça que on a demandé la mission mais
quand une en quelqu'un et exempté de
quelque chose il faut que ce soit pour
les raisons
pour des raisons explicité eux
sinon ce détournement et malsain en
lui-même est donc mais simplement
effectivement on doit regarder certains
sujets en face à la matière d'accords
évidemment avec la formule dix ans
l'école de la république doit faire
envie c'est cette formule sous cette
forme ou sous une autre a été utilisée à
plusieurs reprises dans les débats qui
ont précédé à l'assemblée en particulier
c'est à dire et j'entends ça chez les
acteurs de l'instruction en famille dix
ans mais nous on ne trouve pas notre
compte dans l'école du coin c'est ce que
c'est un peu ce que la sénatrice darcos
a dit aussi ensuite la lah et oui en
effet 2 c'est un défi que de qui est
lancé à l'école de la république que de
que développer son attrait sa mixité
sociale son attractivité
alors vous avez dit et ce qu'on lui en
donne les moyens je comme vous le savez
à cette école de la république de
pouvoir justement tellement attractif
que personne n'a envie d'aller ailleurs
je dis ça avec mes mots maintenant le
jeux comme vous le savez je soutiens
très fortement l'idée que la société du
futur doit reposer sur l'éducation et la
santé sur la capacité de mieux utiliser
notre argent public en le concentrant
davantage sur les enjeux d'éducation et
de santé
c'est un très grand débat mais en tout
cas il se traduit sous ce quinquennat
par le fait qu'il n'y aura jamais autant
d'augmentation budgétaire pour
l'éducation nationale cela fait parfois
débat parce que ces augmentations
budgétaires sont aussi accompagnées de
choix notamment la très grande priorité
accordée à l'école primaire compenser
les retards accumulés en la matière puis
elle grenade le venait de l'éducation
qui correspond aussi à une
requalification de la fonction
professoral donc ça rejoint aussi votre
deuxième question sur le niveau de
recrutement est vraiment j'invite chacun
et d'ailleurs je tiens à disposition de
chacun un exemplaire de d'un document
qui s'appelle le professeur du 21e
siècle qu'il produit du du colloque
réalisé dans le cadre du compte du vent
des de l'éducation avec des
scientifiques et internationaux et et
nos partenaires de façon à déboucher sur
une vision de ce qu'est le professeur au
21e siècle et son niveau de recrutement
le travail en équipe entre les
professeurs plus généralement le
l'épanouissement professionnel des
professeurs donc oui il faut s'en donner
les moyens nous aurons discussion
budgétaire
le moment venu et
je pense que vous verrez un projet de
budget 2022 pour l'éducation qui sera je
l'espère à la hauteur de ce que vous
demandez mais je demande la même chose
là sur les questions de monsieur le
sénateur brisson le le qui est donc j'ai
répondu à un certain point un peu par
avance notamment quand j'ai fait
référence tout à l'heure la formation
initiale des enseignants le donc la
question c'est en quoi ce texte nous
apporte des éléments supplémentaires
pour lutter contre le séparatisme
islamistes je voudrais vraiment jamais à
reprendre tous les arguments de
précédents mais encore une fois il vient
combler certains vides juridiques
existantes dans certains domaines et
s'agissant de l'école de république je
le redis je le dis en introduction nous
avons déjà agi beaucoup et nous allons
continuer à le faire au travers de tous
les dispositifs que j'ai que j'ai
évoqués
donc ensuite la deuxième question c'est
est est ce qu une liberté fondamentale
est conforme avec peut être compatible
avec un régime d'autorisation la réponse
est oui bien entendu
exemple typique c'est le droit de
propriété considérée comme une liberté
fondamentale
depuis la déclaration de 1789 et on peut
faire beaucoup de choses avec sa
propriété mais pas n'importe quoi et
quand on veut construire on a besoin
d'une autorisation
et
mais même une fois qu'on l'a construit à
certaines pollutions par exemple que
l'on ne peut pas faire d' oncle l'on
pourrait multiplier les exemples
oui bien sûr une liberté fondamentale
est compatible avec un régime
d'autorisation puisque comme le dit la
déclaration de 1789 aussi la liberté
s'arrête là où commence celle des autres
et donc on doit avoir une
une liberté confortée par le fait
qu'elle est bien défini donc ne faut-il
pas renforcer le contrôle a demandé le
sénateur brisson et bien c est en effet
ce que nous allons faire et c'est le
sujet des équipements dont j'ai parlé
s'agissant des de la question posée par
malek des questions posées par la
sénatrice darcos là c'est intéressant
que vous est fait référence à l'essonne
votre eau salée il ya plusieurs demeures
au sein de l'essonne si j'ose dire et là
et donc les réalités décrit par le
député choix ne sont pas celles que sont
décrites par la sénatrice darcos mais ça
s'explique sociaux géographiquement
et donc eux
en effet il peut y avoir des familles
qui ne pose pas de problème particulier
même si on peut souhaiter ne serait-ce
coty de la mixité sociale que dans les
différents milieux sociaux se mélange à
l'école il n'en demeure pas moins que je
le redis ce qu'ils font à l'instruction
en famille d'une manière qui ne pose pas
de problème du point de vue des
principes de la république ne soit pour
en continuer simplement les contrôles
seront renforcés et je le redis l'année
prochaine les les
ces contrôles nous permettront de
d'autoriser pour la rentrée suivante je
pense que une partie de ceux qui
s'inquiètent aujourd'hui ça rejoint
aussi les questions du sénateur dessus
tout à l'heure sur la disproportion
entre la cible ce que beaucoup de ceux
qui s'inquiètent aujourd'hui en réalité
seront rassurés je le pense dans dans
quelques mois et là aussi ce sont des
rendez vous que l'on peut se donner pour
pour les temps qui viennent sur les
questions sur l'intervention général du
sénateur hugo neige est un peu répondu
par avance à
une bonne partie de ce qu'il a dit est
prêt dont j'ai pris bonne note
d'accord bien sûr pour redire que la
laïcité est sous le signe de la de la
liberté j'ai dit que c'était pas une
gestation de mode d'émotion c'est même
je crois là un exemple vraiment
rigoureusement rigoureusement inverse
vous nous avez dit que nous ciblions un
groupe sans le nommer en fait pour être
totalement explicite
je ne pense pas qu'on a qu'on conçu
combat à 7 à la citation calcaire de
camus / fait de mal nommer les choses
puisque dès le début le président la
république dans le discours des mureaux
est très clair nous avons un problème
avec le radicalisme islamiste nous avons
parlé avec l'islam politique à nous
avons propres donc oui de la société
française à ce problème à régler
l'associé le les pouvoirs publics font
la différence entre la religion l'islam
et l'islamisme politique où les projets
de prosélytisme des secteurs radicaux et
c'est cette distinction qui est demandé
par la majorité des musulmans de france
d'ailleurs
lesquels sont souvent eux mêmes en
première ligne face au phénomène de
pressions qui peuvent être exercées sur
eux
[Musique]